uh good morning
um and welcome to this meeting of the
mid-suffolk District Council planning
committee uh sorry for the delayed um
start to the meeting but we've just had
a fire alarm go off
uh so may I first all remind you of some
domestic arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use please do not interrupt other
speakers or hold separate conversations
whilst others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and that your
laptops are switched to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and the possible
use of those sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
if you hear the fire alarm things has
gone off once already maybe that might
happen again leave the building
immediately via a far exit and make your
way to the assembly point which is an
Ipswich Town Football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium ground floor area
and walkways if you are in the atrium at
the time of the alarm follow the signs
to the nearest far exit use the stairs
not the lifts and do not re-enter the
building until you're told it's safe to
do so
all right we now need some introductions
for those people who may not be familiar
with planning committees
so we have the members of the planning
committee are on this side of the room
they will be the ones who will be
debating and determining the
applications we have the on the other
side we have the officers we have the
area planning manager at Gemma Walker
um we have the chief planning Officer
Phil Isbell
we have our legal advisor in to pray we
have case officers we've got Vincent
Pierce here and Daniel Cameron will be
coming in to present the second case
we also have
um Sam Harvard Sam Harvey who is the
Suffolk County Council highways
development management technical manager
and we have our governance officers
Claire Philpot Alicia Norman and Beth
Webb who keep us all in order and make
sure the it is working we will also be
having some representation from Ward
members Council Austin Davis and
councilor Terence Carter who will be
joining us for our teams
um so can I move to the agenda please uh
number one apologies for absence and
substitutions do we have any apologies
thank you chair we have apologies from
Council Austin Davies and councilor
David penny is substituting thank you
we now need to receive decorations of
disclosable pecuniary interests and
other registrable or non-registerable
interests by members are there any to
declare
okay uh Declarations of lobbying I think
we've all received emails is that true
we've all received emails on both cases
apart from councilor penny
you not received any emails from the
agents
no because you're a substitute
but everyone else anyone had any other
lobbying other than those ones that were
sent to everybody well
Declarations of personal site visits any
to declare
well
um
so number five we need to confirm the
minutes of the planning committee
meeting held on the 21st of June 2023
um
well there are some minor Corrections
which the governance officer is just
going to uh
thank you chair yes so in paragraph 9.6
the ward member for elmsworld has been
corrected to Jen over it and in
paragraph 14.6 we've made a correction
to the spelling of Jen over its name
thank you
are there any other points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
um so could I have a proposer for the
minutes councilor Madison and seconder
councilor having um
so we now need to have an electronic
vote
um for the minutes
that vote is now in progress
Council Harding in my UK or do you want
me to take your vote
shall I take it verbally and I can add
it in afterwards yep
thank you
it's no problem thank you chair that's
seven votes for and one abstention
okay so the minutes have been approved
and been confirmed and will be signed at
the end of the meeting item number six
on our agenda is to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme do we
have any non-received yet
okay uh so we now move to item seven the
schedule of planning applications uh we
will do the order as they are printed in
the agenda so we start with DC
2001716 land to the north side of Norton
Road Thurston Suffolk and I think we
have
um a presentation from the planning
officer Vincent Pierce and it's going to
incorporate some comments from Sam
Harvey about the highways so over to You
Vince
thank you chair good morning members our
guests and anyone who may be watching
and listening remotely
I was hoping that we could start the
meeting with Sam just giving you a quick
explanation of where we are we are terms
of
the Bunbury arms Junction to the north
of Thurston because it may or may not
have a bearing on some of the discussion
this morning I know a lot of members are
anxious to understand where we are with
progress with that Junction so if I may
Sam are you happy to
everyone
so some background to development with
regard to highways previous planning
applications they were the first and
five there was 818 dwellings
to ensure that all developments were
taken into account Suffolk County
Council along with baby baby mid-suffolk
commissioned an independent consultant
Acom
using the traffic data to model
Junctions servers that we could ensure
that they're all capacity and if they
were over capacity then what mitigation
was required
so from this the contribution section
106 contributions from the first and
five
there was The a143 Junction at Bunbury
arms traffic signal installation was
required and the budget sum for that was
350 000 pounds
there are other mitigations 30 mile hour
speed limit extension on ixsworth Road
Norton Road and Barton Road
new speed limit at fyshwick corner along
with some traffic calming pedestrian
Crossing facilities at Norton Road
igsworth Road and station Hill
zebra Crossings on Norton Road and
public rights of way improvements
which totaled uh 96 000 just for the
106 delivery from those sites at the
moment the extensions to Norton Road
ixsworth Road and Barton Road have all
been completed the two zebra Crossings
on Norton Road
originally it was only for a single
Crossing but when the school came
forward we had to find some money to put
the second zebra Crossing in
their Bunbury arms Junction detailed
design has been commissioned
and the 40 mile hour speed limit
installed on Fisher corner but the
design improvements have not gone
forward due to the Baton Road
improvements now delivery of Bunbury
arms
Suffolk highways is our delivery service
for Suffolk County Council on
commissioned to design the improvements
the design was added to the program
for the design team however when covid
hit
new traffic active travel schemes took
priority over any section 106 schemes
as they didn't at the time have a Time
trigger
and they were put back in a design
program
there were engineering difficulties with
the junction as those existing services
BTU mainly and the picture that you have
up on the screen at the moment shows you
where the BT box is that becomes a lane
that turns into a lane for either left
turn
or straight on because we have to have a
right turn lane in the middle of the
a143 for anybody wanting to turn left or
right at that crossroads
the BT did come back with us were the
cost estimate which was very high we
have now gone back to them with a
another request for a more detailed
estimate which very often comes back
half the price
they just put in an initial idea of how
much it could cost
at the moment we
've again the small
yesterday
of that we still have not heard back so
we're
assuming that it's either lost hoping is
not lost in The Ether but we we're
thinking that the gentleman we're
talking to is on leave
however another thing that's added to it
Suffolk highways contract is changing
provider in September October so all
works have been stopped on any designs
which again has put time back on the
program back but I've been told that it
is within the program for the new
contract and it will continue to design
in October
so hopefully back by the time in October
we have the BT estimate and we have
everything that we need to be able to
progress the design I've spoken to the
developers to find out what the
occupancy is at the moment for the first
and five one of which has not come
forward yet they haven't started any
um building of dwellings
and if you average out all the occupancy
for the four that have been built uh
that are progressing it's 75 occupied so
I think as a as Suffolk County Council
we would like to be progressing this
Junction especially with 75 occupancy
there are
um
there are a team who aren't know that
this is a high priority
and if necessary I have been talking to
your chairman and I have been talking to
the chief planning officer to see if if
we need any more leverage to bring this
program even further forward than we are
working our way into getting Bunbury
arms
actually working with traffic signals
thank you
so that is Sam Harvey's update I don't
know whether any questions yeah
um Sam Harvey can't stay
um very long in the meeting and I know
that may have been a bit out of context
for people who aren't familiar with the
concept of the first and five which was
granted some time ago
um did anyone have any questions of the
highways officer now because she may
have to leave
um in about 20 minutes
uh Council of War boys
thank you chair uh yeah yes just just
clarify I understand that
um
the delays of the Bunbury arms Junction
are all the level Crossings
up to date and on are they completed
Crossing sorry
I spoke
yeah the um The Pedestrian Crossings
except are all in except for the one
that's outside the library on station
Hill Junction with Norton Road and
nixworth road we we haven't progressed
that one at this time
it was originally going to be put
forward by the gladman site but so
that's why we've sat on it obviously
that ones that appeal at the moment so
once we know the outcome of that then
that will be put into the program maybe
or maybe not dependent on the decision
thank you councilor Matheson did I see
your hand go up
um yeah I I really
um yeah I'd really like to understand
the detail of the the
um occupancy
um the you know the trigger points and
so on
I have been involving some of this stuff
previously
certainly remember reading the detail
about the Bunbury arms and and yeah
um whether either officers got
um a bit more detail they can you know
tell us of
how many 100 of which site or whatever
um
is is the point at which we need
to have more of these things in place
and I seem to remember the the Bunbury
arms one was critical on about three of
the sites
everything helps a bit more on that
all I can tell you from section 106
point of view is that as far as I know
there are no triggers for it to come
forward the only triggers are for them
when to pay
for The Works to be done so and I
believe it's on start of Works was when
they all paid for the 106 and that there
is a time restraint of it's got to be
spent within 10 years or we have to
return it I can't tell you whether or
not there was anything with the
conditions
um for Bunbury eyes because of course
it's a contribution so it goes out of
the developers and it goes out the
planner's hands as soon as the money is
paid to Suffolk I do believe but um my
colleagues may be able to let me know
I mean I you know I think the problem
clearly is is
are the trigger points or whatever
of the the
infrastructure being physically improved
um uh
to to meet the occupancy of these five
sites and
um
I think that's going to become quite
important in the discussion I think Mr
Isbell would like to come in
thank you Jim I might not be able to
answer councilman's question directly
but
um
Sam is
probably correct about
the way in which the delivery mechanism
for Bunbury art Junction was expected to
I know there are interests locally both
in the works there and around fyshwick
corner which
the Bunbury arms Junction Works were
funded by the first and five as they're
called and and this is one of those
sites and an increasing number on one of
those sites but the delivery of that was
expected and fell to the hands of the
County Council and therefore in terms of
timing I think the County Council wanted
to be
processes to get
is to get delivered and I can't speak to
it this morning
I'm conscious though that there is a
local interest as well in the fyshwick
corner Junction
as we might not otherwise
I don't know events whether we have a
plan a locality we could put up which
for the sake of reference in relation to
Thurston describes all of these
Junctions because by name they have
become
a planning committee and it can help
um and and on that in relation to
okay
so
wait one
that'll that'll do so
I'll try and describe it so the Bunbury
Junction should be familiar to most
people and they and the key highway
consideration the point of town that the
five
major developments uh were considered by
this committee some years ago
there was concern at the time about
pokeridge corner
is just off the screen to the south side
of the Railway line here
accident spot and there was concern
about fyshwick corners and debate with
the highway Authority at
concluded that
the Bunbury arms Junction required
remediation works but neither poke
region or Fishwick did from those
developments by reason of the harm cause
subsequently blue replied and their site
is is effectively just off the bottom of
that screen um
members will I'm sure probably be aware
that there was uh litigation in relation
to that and that site has not has yet
come forward that site included
Improvement Works which went across the
boundary with West Suffolk to deliver
Improvement Works to that Fishwick
Corner Junction I think that and I may
speak Captain yes um is going through
Highway Authority processes at the
moment so I think it's still to be
delivered
and
our expectation is that law will be
delivering their site and that those
Improvement Works will take place I have
seen correspondence this week
and are those Junction improvements are
I would ask Sarah if you could just
comment on that when I've wrapped up but
in terms of both of those Highway
elements it's important to remember
we're dealing with one site which
already has planning permission and
perhaps the question for this committee
is not so much it is interesting to get
the context I appreciate but the
question is whether this development
causes additional harm such that
additional Highway Improvement works are
necessary and I think
to put it in very bold terms the highway
Improvement Works which are necessary to
mitigate the occupancy are already
funded and planned for the delivery of
them is partly in the hands of the
County Council to make sure that happens
and to that extent we are alive as
officers to the need to get on with it
regardless of what the triggers may or
may not be
clearly that is infrastructure that
infrastructure is necessary to support
these houses but in terms of the
application before you this morning
a change to one site
I'm not convinced that this gives rise
to additional highways impacts
which will be unacceptable and require
additional mitigation thank you
thank you
um any further questions regarding the
highways
um if not then we'll move on to the rest
of your presentation events
just to remind members we're actually
looking at a full application and an
outline application at the same time so
it is a hybrid application the full
application involves the construction of
112 filings and the outline element is
for nine self-build plots now many of
you will recall that we have already
granted outline planning permission for
up to 200 dwellings and we've approved
two Reserve matters which actually take
the number of dwellings to 191.
those some of those are under
construction so to help explain a
conundrum of numbers
I have
tried to put it in pictorial form so
that is the site and originally
you permitted up to 200 dwellings
we approved a reserved matters phase one
for 87 dwellings
which brought the total from down from
200 so there were 113 dwellings left to
go
we then approved a second phase which
comprised 104 dwellings
which brought that 200 down to nine
remaining
the nine remaining was accounted for by
self-build
that's how you got to the 200 but what
you're looking at today is
the insertion of a new phase comprising
112 dwellings within what was previously
known as phase two
that brings the previous total for phase
two of 104
down to 53.
when you add the nine self-build
total goes up
over and above the Outline by 61
dwellings so the overall total if you
did approve the application would then
be 261.
so this first phase is um
almost complete workers started on this
phase
so if you grant your permission today
what would happen is that part of the
second phase will be built out and then
this part would change and they'd be
implementing the permission for 112.
hopefully this will work if I just press
that just to familiarize members so that
a slightly so here we are traveling East
along
Norton Road on the right
at least we're just
Meadow View
started the Cavendish view development
on the left with properties fronting the
Road there's a cycleway crossing the
route now that goes to the primary score
you'll notice how the layout has been
designed so the buildings front
the road even when it curves as you
drive
lady Road at the end of that view is the
Crescent it's been designed so that as
you turn to the left the Crescent opens
up to view
and we simply swing around as you can
see it's a contemporary styled
state has our most of the other new
builds in in Thurston and as you look
towards the distance there's areas of
Woodland and that little Gateway is
start of the next phase of development
if we stand at the Northern end of the
site which would be open space and we
just quickly scan round you can see how
before that
that is when I went out yesterday that
was full of butterflies the public
footpath cuts across that and then
swings around
towards the left into the Woodland
the development
off on the right in the distance
obviously it will get closer but there
is a large area of open space retained
at the Northern end of the site
this is actually the drainage base of
them we're actually very pleased with
how that's turned out
scanned
that is what we hope to see rather than
the ones that you might be familiar with
which is just a sort of rectangular base
of with cut grass
this one has been designed to um
look far more natural and we're very
pleased with the way that's turned out
we're going to take a quick drive up
Meadow Lane because the character of
Meadow Lane is an important factor in in
terms of the neighborhood plan and how
you consider the application before you
Meadow Lane very distinctive it clearly
is
Country Lane very few properties the
properties the older properties are all
on the left they're some rather lovely
Flint
cottages on the right is Cavendish view
most of that is completely hidden by the
existing Flora that would remain the Gap
you see there is where the temporary
construction access was that's all been
replanted and it will all look like
you see on the right so any new
development sits behind that um
an established hedge line and that was
taken yesterday
so in terms of the character of meadow
Elena I would argue that the new
development is is well hidden and it
actually retains its lovely Country Lane
field
the road stops there and if you just
walk
into the distance you then walk along
path seven which is actually
very beautiful it's all overhun by by
trees you'd think you were absolutely in
the middle of nowhere and I guess at one
time you would have been
view across and we just see the the
Eastern side of
lady greens Plantation so that's the
Cavendish view development that's
Linden's development in the distance
was taken with the zoom lens so actually
that disappears Into The View when you
actually stand there you can see how
well wooded
as part of thirst it is
in fact Gap is
um part of the open space and some of
the development for Cavendish View
to remind members that Thurston is a key
service center
and our policies do prescribe the
majority of new development will be
directed towards towns and key service
centers
it's fair to say that Thurston has had a
significant amount of
new development probably more than any
other settlement in the district but it
is a key service center
I'm sure you're all familiar with the
location but it sits just to the north
of the A14 east of Paris and Edmonds
in terms of a
closer view we're right on the edge of
West Suffolk and the application
societies is flashing in in red on that
screen
so
whilst Thurston has expanded very
recently you can actually see how recent
a lot of that has been
the
aerial photograph that's the base
photograph was taken in July 2018 and
you can see by June 2023
a matter of five years there has been a
huge amount of development on the north
side
of Thurston and the red outline is the
application site and you can see some of
that construction is already completed
in terms of
us can cross the Northwestern corner and
there are listed buildings
to the east
terms of
flood risk
and over the other the flood area
actually runs through the Woodland it
doesn't
interfere with the developable area of
this site or the houses that we've
already approved
as I say we've already approved a
drainage basin that was designed to
accommodate all the flows from this
development
and Suffolk County Council now use this
as an Exemplar in all of their
public literature
to give you another
idea of a setting and the context the
new Primary School
sitting there just to the east of the
application site
Community College just to the West
the
white arrows are the first and five
sites and the pink error at the bottom
is the blur development of 210 dwellings
that we'll be commencing shortly
station nestling at the bottom or middle
left
that shows you how the phases pan out
some of the key attractions in the
village in terms of services and
Facilities
before I go on I just want to emphasize
the concerns and objections of Thurston
Parish Council they are set out in full
in the report and as you can see
as the scheme has amended Thurston
Parish Council has maintained its its
Egyptian
and pick out
what I think are the key parts of their
latest almost up-to-date
objection I've put these five points if
Vicky is speaking from the parish
council she may have a different View
and I just stress this is simply a
summary
so the main concern one of the main
concerns is that having granted a
permission for up to 200 that is what
the parish wanted that's what they
expected
261 is unacceptable
the parish council and many of the
Community they see an extra 60 one
that's overcrowding the site
potentially putting more of a strain on
facilities and services in the village
and I think to some degree 200 should
mean 200.
particularly when it was so
controversial at that time
so just to emphasize the number of units
is considered acceptable the parish
council feel that the character of the
latest scheme does not meet the
requirements of the adopted Thurston
neighborhood development plans and we'll
look into that in a little bit more
detail as we go through
there's a feeling from the parish
council the scheme fails to promote
quality design
and that is a key thread in the name of
the plan it's a key thread in National
design guidance and of course it is a
growing priority for the government
first can also feel that the applicant
hasn't demonstrated the sustainability
of The Proposal we will quickly pick up
on all of these points as
but that's a summary but I'm sure
members will have read the full
objections from Thurston
and will no doubt have questions
as a result of that
although it's in the report I just want
to highlight
two policies from the neighbor plan
policy one which deals with
spatial strategy I think
I have to emphasize that the policy says
that new development will be focused
within the settlement boundary this site
is within the settlement boundary
the policy also says that such proposals
will be supported within the settlement
subject to that development complying
with other policies in the neighborhood
plan as you can see Thurston Parish
Council feels that the development fails
on that particular test because they
take the view that it fails other
policies in the neighborhood plan
to emphasize the solid black line is the
settlement boundary and the flashing red
is the application site sitting Within
the settlement boundary
the neighborhood plan extended the
settlement boundary to embrace what we
now call the Thurston five sites
we also need to dip into well not dip we
need to dive in deeply into policy four
which deals with design and on the
screen I've
think put down why I think it it
complies and I'm sure
test and have a different view but we
will pick up all of those points as we
go through
first and Parish Council having said
that it it isn't the character isn't
appropriate we now need to look at the
character assessment that was undertaken
for the neighborhood plan the flashing
red is the
application site and you can see the the
closest character areas character area
three which is Meadow Lane so this site
sits outside of the character area
number three but clearly it has to have
regard to it and as I showed you in that
very quick video it is very distinctive
very few dwellings although
before new dwellings in here as part of
the Thurston
five but the scattering of rather lovely
Flint Cottages is about there
clearly since the character assessment
for Area 3 was devised the council has
admitted to 200 dwellings the whole
character of the land on the
side of Meadow Lane has changed for good
but what I was trying to emphasize in
the video is that
other than for that little Gap where the
compound excess used to be you'd be
hard-pressed to notice this in terms of
visual as you're walking or driving
along
Meadow Lane
first and as we know it in terms of
character here's a older survey map from
1968.
and actually
Thurston seemed to hardly exist in terms
of the dwellings that and properties
that were in the village at that time so
clearly
what has happened is we're just getting
up so the green is
lady greens Plantation so you can see
how open it all was even as I say
recently that's probably a long time ago
to a lot of people now but as recently
as 1968 it was really quite open it was
a quiet little village
in mid-suffolk
if we superimpose the outskirts of
Thurston in July 2018 you you see that
all that development has happened after
1968.
first and as we know it no longer exists
perhaps we knew it no longer exists
it has been
overshadowed by
modern development
there I'm emphasizing the how Meadow
Lane the land on the East has completely
transformed it's no longer open
Countryside
in terms of character area 4 which is
just to the Southwest that is again a
relatively late 20th century estate
and if you look at the layout it has
similarities to what is now being
proposed it has these long access roads
with a series of cul-de-sacs
off of it
if we're trying to mimic the character
within character area four
is similar to that character
I would argue
that's character area for there
so in terms of the layout that's being
proposed now we're just assuming it's as
you see it on the screen
break that down what happens is you can
see the loop existing Loop Road which is
a lady road that goes around to
pondfield Road and the school is off the
bottom on the right
connections to the countryside the green
arrows
here is a West East pedestrian link
through the development there are a
series of those through the earlier
parts of the development that route is
well surveilled by properties
overlooking it
the units there are set well back from
Meadow Lane as were the units in phase
one
the existing Hedgerow is retained
to the west of that
dashed line
street is closed with a a proper view it
isn't left hanging open so you're
looking into people's garages or fencing
or something less desirable visually
we have rented affordable housing
we have
shared
ownership affordable housing
are clustered in numbers
[Music]
oh
I'll turn the switch off now can you
um each of those is clustered in in
sizes that meet our our usual customer
and practice less than 15.
can I carry on and just ignore the
rustling if I can the next little area
that we'll look at in more detail is the
lowest density area on the East adjacent
to
lady greens Plantation so again
connections to the countryside it has
its own little
area of green overlooked by dwellings
the whole of that Eastern side is well
surveilled at the moment
on that screen
in a sense this is almost a reference
back to the idea of the Crescent where
we've asked
the curve the buildings round to
hug the road as it goes around so and
that simply emphasizes the extent of the
this part of the low density element
within this scheme
and right at the top we have
affordable rented units we have some
shared ownership
again in the cluster of less than 15 we
have
Bungalows
those members who are here when we dealt
with the earlier phases will remember
that there were significant numbers of
bungalows in the earlier phases we've
carried that through
and in our terms we think this is
helping to
cater for downsizers also
older members of the community and
that's a priority in the neighborhood
plan
in terms of this development we've
actually got an increased number of two
and three bedroom units again which is
catering for the younger buyer and again
that's a theme within the neighborhood
plan that's seen as a priority so we've
we've lost some of the larger four and
five bid units
but if the the increase of units is
accounted for by more smaller units
and again those units are sent back and
the word the Hedgerow is retained
and that's the plots for the self-build
in terms of the house types you've seen
a number of these before because they've
been used in Phase One and phase two
again nicely proportioned Gables
interesting features Bays
and simple but
elegant porches rub brick arches nice
Dormer details and
again
on the two and a half story or you might
say three story but historian attic
accommodation
there are a few of these
these previously have caused the parish
council concern we have approved them
elsewhere but as you can see the
designed
was amended originally so that the
proportions are are elegant previously
they had large Dormers and the whole
thing looked how to proportion that is a
nicely proportioned elevation
and those sorts of themes are carried on
so here you've got um
terrorists of three
with a
portion of
lean-to porch you may have a debate as
to which looks more elegant but they're
all it is nicely designed
there's a lot of interest in those
elevations they've been where they are
grouped together in tourists they put
together nicely
it's been this sort of arrangement in
Phase One and phase two
there are some Mason Nets
I've been through plot By plot all of
the parking meets your parking standards
in terms of the garage sizes gaps
between buildings where you have a
building
space building there is at least three
meters
that fully accommodates your desires in
terms of there are no Triplex spaces
in terms of
where there are Triplex spaces where
they're over providing
so we've actually gone in this state
where I can't find one that the false
foul of your customer practice
that wasn't an accident I know we've
worked with Lyndon to make sure that
happens in terms of densities because
clearly the parish council
The View that 200 should mean 200 we
also have to have regard to what does
that do in terms of density if raised it
were you to Grant permission to 261. so
crude estimate density at the moment if
we include the area of Woodland
it's incredibly low
12.9
or thereabouts
Woodland it's
21 which is still well below your normal
starting point on Modern development of
30.
now I think and I don't want to speak
for me keeping it sounds as though I am
I think the argument is what has been
approved is the character of development
that is reflective of that low density
if we then increase the numbers the
character will change
my argument is when you look at
this proposal compared to the previous
two phases and all of the previous first
and five
character is identical in terms of how
it looks from the street
now is it reasonable for you as a
committee to insist on a character
that is now actually could be said to
represent inefficient use of land when
land is so scarce and the pressure on
Greenfield sites is high
is this a way of accommodating
development without having to
spread out onto new sites and you'll
have your own views
just to compare with other sites the
Danbury development
16.9 so that's actually low
Lawrence Holmes 20.6
bovis 24.8
persimmon 28.7 and within the persimmon
development there are
Parcels of land where the density is
actually 59 dwellings per hectare and of
course that spreads out across the site
and reduces to 28 because the larger
units are set in bigger plots
I think I was asked what does that mean
in terms of people well here's a crude
estimate so at the moment with the 200
I believe you would have
expect something like 204 people
based on the number of bedrooms in that
scheme
a current proposal push that to 422 so
the extra 61 units say there are three
in each you can see how that quickly
it goes up
but
all of our console teams in terms of the
section 106 have based their
requirements for educational
contributions
Etc on the unbraided figure
first in this well served by cycle route
cycle route National cycle Route 51 go
straight through it
an enviable number of bus stops some
might think for a rural location
a number of services
by comparison what seems to be a decent
frequency of
trains
and that is the one big advantage of
Thurston that perhaps has singled it out
for
for new development having a station
in terms of the submitted traffic
appraisal and this is something that has
been looked at by Suffolk Council
there are no concerns about impact on
the
highway system arising from an increase
of 61 dwellings
what about sustainability and energy
well what we've um
we've got here is a scheme that is
purported to exceed building rigs by
nearly 60 percent all 112 dwellings will
have air source heat pumps
all 43 affordable units will also have
PV panels
will help pack all issues of fuel
poverty
people at least able to afford high
energy costs hopefully will get some
respite from that we will secure a
hundred percent
electric vehicle charging
all open market units will have an
option for purchases to have PV put on
the roof at the time of construction
public EV charging terminal will be
provided with
100 of the affordable units beat ndss
at 97 of the open market units
will meet ndss there are two units which
four bidders which don't meet the target
but in terms of people buying four bed
units if they want to buy them
property there then let them do so
lots of habitat creation with so much
Wetland area being created there's some
exciting opportunities to boost
biodiversity
we were also negotiated and Linda have
agreed to a cycleway extension so the
existing Crossing on Norton Road by the
primary school
the cycle route will be extended north
of that
in order to get people to the primary
school
from that Crossing at the moment it's
just grasp urge
so in terms of the arrowed things on
that screen we're actually achieving 100
I can't think of any other development
where we've
managed to get people to put air source
heat pumps in and PV on the leather
roofs at the same same time
I haven't given you all the landscape
drawings but I put this one up on the
screen to show you that there is a
significant amount of new tree planting
and I know that's something that's
important to the council in terms of
helping to tackle climate change there
are a lot of trees going in on the
scheme
play area which is located in the open
space
again more trees around the Little
Village Green area in the center of the
development
made about the extent of greenery on
frontages so well I've highlighted there
is where planting
I think it's true to say we could
actually get more so where I've
added that bit of green
were you to approve this proposal there
is a condition that says
we will go over that plan one more time
and identify more locations where we can
actually get us the sort of character
that
the parish council have included in the
neighborhood plan in terms of those two
diagrams that are taken from the Suffolk
design guide
Lyndon have agreed that they'd be happy
to do that
in terms of connectivity there's
excellent connectivity north south west
east
the 106 agreement Linden can agreed to
extend
formally Parish liaison scheme and in
Thurston that has been working well it's
something that we now require of all
developments
and this is where Bunbury arms comes
into play Linden have agreed
to contribute 50 000 pounds towards the
installation of mover technology
and mover technology is software that
will monitor traffic flowy in real time
and change the lights in order to keep
cues down
the first and five scheme didn't include
that technology so the lighting regime
would be fixed on day one
so Linden homes will be contributing to
the Bunbury arms we've obviously got the
education contributions
interestingly and I think I think
welcome
I would say it's welcome Lyndon have
agreed that
were the
Legends came to fail
appointment the council is making
earlier about the crossings on Norton
Road by the the old library
we wouldn't be getting those provided by
Gladwin if the appeal failed Linden have
offered to put one in on the back of
this uplift and
C1 so
we would require that by section 106 and
if the cloudman appeal was allowed then
we would use that contribution somewhere
else in Thurston from
and there are a lot more the list goes
on but this is all in the all in the
report so
based on that subject to a 106 to
achieve those things what we're
recommending to the committee is that
can be granted for the hybrid but that
permission be delegated to the chief
planning officer
to issue that once section 106 agreement
has been completed to his satisfaction
thank you chair
thank you do we have any questions from
members
councilor Mathison your hand went up
first yeah
um yeah well perhaps if I start with the
questions that have stemmed from from
watching the officer's report and then
I'll let a few other people ever go
while they'll look at some of the
earlier ones that I've found really in
the papers
um can we have a look at
slide 26 please
that's the the layout shown where the
affordable
homes are I must say I wasn't really
very convinced that um that we were
effectively spreading them across the
site
and they look very much to me as if the
three little groups were actually more
or less
all one big group actually if you take
the where are we now
um
so that's the
the
that's just about one
um what were the so they're the rental
ones they're the shared ownership and if
we go one back
ah so if I go quick you can see how they
yeah I was just trying to see the two
lots together frankly and you know the
answer really is that those two whole
blocks
are nearly a bit you know to me that's
more or less
um 30.
affordable units in one big group really
um I just wanted to be clear about what
what we're seeing there
um second question and this might be for
the for the agent
um the the tenure of bungalows
um yes you've got
um there's there's a foldable and and um
Market rent market for sale bungalows
but on my reading that all the all the
m42 and and m43
um
accessible and livable in
um people with disabilities Etc seem to
all be in the affordables and and there
seems to be a wrong assumption there uh
that you know the people that have done
well in life and have got lots of money
nevertheless
we want to we'll want to move into a
bungalow and which is an m43
so that's the that's the second question
that that if that my understanding you
can confirm whether I'm reading that
correctly that is a correct
that is correct what there are they're
all but they're all on there for them
yeah okay well we'll take that up again
with the age and if we may and um
yeah I wanted to just another look at
that slide 40 that showed the number of
people that was a bit too that was a bit
too quick for me to see how it was that
it gone up so much
yeah so
can you tell us why the number seems to
have gone up dramatically more than the
number of extra units
without me pulling the whole slide so it
took me five minutes
four away from the 400 and 22 that's
about 4 220.
61 times 4
gives us
that gives us the the uplift
full people so a three bedroom unit I
would expect four people
so the extras are mainly three bedroom
well I think yeah the figures are in in
effect
see
betters were
four there's now 30.
three bed there were eight and there's
now 26.
so there is an emphasis on that side of
you
anyone else got a question uh Council
Elkin
I just wondered if that had implications
for play Space
um if that was changing at all
um I know it was something that the
parish council were concerned about they
had a number of of issues whether it was
strategically placed
um to sort of link with other other play
areas in the community they said there
was a lack of sort of Adventure style
play equipment for older children
um and I was wondering if there was any
provision for children with disabilities
so yeah I just wondered if if there's
denser housing and more people whether
that had an impact for that provision
thank you
in terms of
impact as I say this this
will include a play area
whether or not
there's an interesting point about it I
suspected designed specifically to cater
for
and that's an interesting point and
perhaps it
should and that might be something that
we could condition further in terms of
the detail of that play area so that we
can make sure that it it does achieve
that objective
Fair
a fair point
in terms of play areas obviously each of
those first and five schemes are
providing their their own facilities
whether or not there is a need for a
neep which is the neighborhood equipped
area play that's an interesting question
I mean this site is big enough to
accommodate
Within
can't justify that on the back of an up
list of 61 dwellings but there has been
a lot of debate about who gets to manage
and own the open space
and it will be managed by linden in
terms of a management company it won't
be transferred either to the district
council or the parish council I think
the parish council were quite Keen to
to get their hands if they could manage
it for the
community
and that might be a question you want to
ask at Linden but my understanding is
and I've discussed this with them is
that because they've already set up that
management company and because that
management company within its portfolio
now
space and residents are paying a service
charge based on that they now cannot
undo that
now whether or not as a result of Parish
liaison they might be open to the United
facilities on it
through neighborhood still District sill
or other developer contributions is an
interesting point
I'd like to think they'd be open to it
but you
want directly
uh councilor had him
thank you I realized that the self
builds are outlined but what parameters
is there what sort of you know what
limits or whatever do we put on that
at the moment none
in terms of the earlier consents none
what we have discussed with Lyndon is
that we if you were minded to Grant it
we could either put it as a condition or
even in the 106. that we come up with a
we agree a design and sustainability
statement which actually sets down some
key principles so that anyone purchasing
one of these plots
would have something to aim for that
they they would
now whether or not members like that
idea is something for you to
but it is now on the table as a
potential
that we could get involved in that with
them
come back
the question completely um the hillside
supreme court judgment thing can you
just go over that again what that means
like if we just say can we why not just
build the 200 or whatever
our understanding our interpretation at
the moment is
that
in terms of what happens today that's
not a matter for this committee
there is an argument that says on the
hillside that if the implementation of
this element were it to be approved
doesn't adversely impact
developers the ability to finish the
earlier phases that may or may not be
sufficient to get past the hillside test
but as I'm not a lawyer
I'm quite happy for Mr Dupree or
or the chief planning position give us
further advice but as far as we're
concerned this morning that isn't
something we believe it's not something
for the committee
did you want to make a comment Mr Duprey
I've
I don't believe
so much case law that says if
even if something is in turns out to be
impossible the applicant is entitled to
ask us for permission for it so we
should still go ahead today and
determine it on its merits and
Health the hillside principle is is a
bit nuanced and there may be there may
be a way a lawful way of the applicant
um doing something by way of something
like a section 73 application to modify
the phasing provision of the outline
that was
2018 that would remove possibly remove
any doubt as to whether it was
implementable so I think I I would say I
would suggest
carry on for the time being without work
without worries on that score
Mr Isabel
well I haven't been invited to speak I
may as well take the opportunity Jim um
yes I mean as as Mr Price says I think
the thing is for any large residential
Society the hillside case and judge
developers and the local planning
Authority
's Point here and the advice received is
that because this is a discrete parcel
of the site a discrete phase you can
deal with it and it does not trespass on
the hillside principle so our advice to
you as committee and obviously committee
relies upon its officers to guide Our
advice is that you can proceed to
determine this and does not alter the
enforceability of the existing planning
permission
the rest of this would take a very long
time to go into with the aid of diagrams
go down the table Council Lawrence
my concern here is that um having had
previous permission 200
and on the baby market and sold it on
the basis of high
quality density and everything else and
an applicant is able to come back two or
three years later and say no ignore that
we're now going to reduce now I noticed
still quite high of good in terms of
density levels in comparison to other
sites but two wrongs don't make a right
and if the developer wanted to build 261
units on this side why wasn't it applied
for in the first place
where there may be more difficult at
that time getting me with permissions
thank you
the planning system is such that
the landowner developer can make as many
applications as they like and we have a
duty to determine those on their merits
so whilst
the community may have hoped that 200
meant 200 and if you refused it it
probably would still mean it's 200 but
in terms of
what is the harm
you have as a committee have to identify
the harm caused and we've I touched on
character
and you'd be
you've got to try and think about
is the difference in character so
significant that it justifies a refusal
as office is what we're suggesting is
all of those house types have been used
on the earlier phases or most of them
have been used on the earlier phases so
if it's a question you don't like the
design of the properties we've already
approved them they're there
and I think they look they look
okay in terms of modern housing so what
would the distinction be in terms of the
density and as I've set out in the
report
be a looser feel to the properties they
would sit on larger plots there would be
more Greenery
is that enough to justify
a refusal
when what is being created you find on
all of the first and five sites and
that's something only you can answer as
members that's for you to to Grapple
with and come up with your your answer
but in the report I have tried to set
out what
density of eight dwellings to the
hectare would look like in terms of
called The Arcadian character
unfortunately the earlier phase whilst
there is a parcel at eight
it doesn't actually achieve the layout
that you could say was was Arcadian and
it all starts seemed a bit theoretical
but a density of eight to the head is
now unheard of
it is actually inefficient use of
of land
and that's the Dilemma
do we aim for something that's Arcadian
pushes development somewhere else
there's no no developer today wants to
develop an ape
to the hectare
you may say well
time for a change
the reality is that eight is just
inefficient these days it looks
wonderful
it doesn't help you meet your housing
targets if you're only doing eight to
the hectare
we do have a 10-year yes
can you put your mic on
my view there's no proven need to
increase I think we're we're veering
onto um debate so can we just stick some
questions for now uh councilor
hardingham
um the the North West part of the
development
um from your illustration which shows
the density of housing
um
is actually quite dense
um you've got got it down as being 50
dwellings per hectare and the national
design guide so it's the outer suburbs
should be normally of a density of about
20 to 40 drawings per hectare so
um would it not be true to say that
um you haven't really got a
Northern end of the of the development
which shows a more loose and
low identity housing have it approaches
the the rural Hinterland
I think you could argue that
were you so minded
um and a further point in that end of
the year State you've got the self-built
houses
um is there any view as to how long they
might take to get finished
and if it would go on for a very long
time which can happen I think we've
self-built then you've got a very ragged
Edge to the
to the development
um and all the open space is beyond that
so that it forms a a rather unattractive
Edge to the development for a number of
years
and gets finished off
I would agree
we don't have control over delivery
times and it could look ragged
the same argument
point was raised when we looked at phase
two
and I hadn't put it on as a condition
here but perhaps I should have done what
we had before was the
the rear boundary that would be exposed
was shown as fencing and we said that
had to be a war unless in the interim
properties have been built the
self-built have been built the other
side
I didn't transfer that across and I
think I should have done because a wall
it made me see more urban is a is a
better screen than a series of
fences but it doesn't overcome the point
that you're really getting at is how
long will that sit there exposed and we
don't have an answer
to that because it depends on I guess
how the sites are marketed it might be
something you want to ask Linda and how
they intend to try and Market those
those plots
okay and I couldn't disagree with you
members the point that councilor
hardingham is is Raising at the moment
about the northwest corner
it's helpful to know you can see it then
as well thank you
so page 80.
am I able just to add a point yeah
obviously I've looked at the parcels
and that they are contributing to the
overall density which was
wrapped earlier but I have to say if I'm
if I'm arguing that the whole design
ethos was to have the lower densities on
the edges
50.
isn't the lowest density on the edge
cannot deny that that is that is a fact
Council so
thank you um
councilor War boys
uh yeah just a slight 28
I I didn't notice it in the bundle I've
only just noticed it as a
you projected it
yeah up in the um
top right hand corner there's a pumping
station
um do those generate a lot of noise with
those buildings adjacent to them need
additional
noise insulation
my understanding is there would be a 15
meter
exclusion area so I provided the
property was more than 15 meters from
the actual equipment
they wouldn't
be a nuisance it wouldn't you okay so
that's so we just make sure that that is
15 meters away uh-huh
and there is some screening and Vegeta
so thank you and the other one was um
you mentioned um
the building regs
would exceed
be exceeded by 58.9
um could you translate that into an
energy performance certificate for me
whether or not Linda
Lynn can do it that figure was produced
by Linden's consultant so
I can't I can't translate that
okay so I will
thank you
uh Council Elkin
um sorry if this has been touched on but
with the self-built plots is there any
way of sort of securing that they meet
similar environmental standards to the
other homes in terms of having
um air source heat pumps for example
I'm hoping that that's some the sort of
thing that we could wrap it wrap up into
this design and sustainability statement
that that if members were minded to
approve we could work on and perhaps get
our sustainability people to work
directly with Linden to come up with
some
High
levels so that would be the mechanism
so just keep keep that in mind when we
come to that part of the um
meeting
um councilor Mathison have you got some
more brief questions uh because did you
say yeah I think councilor hardingham
also wants to come back but but we do
want to
um
not go for too long yeah I appreciate
that
um yeah so the the Hedge with Meadow
Lane I mean are we are we adequately
protecting that we've seen so many many
cases where it all looks marvelous on on
um on the pictures at the committee and
then in reality Hedges just disappear
one way and another I see that they're
not in anybody's Back Garden which is
helpful but
um I just wonder whether we need more
more to ensure that they that's
particularly that hedge is actually
retained second question
the the sustainable drainage system
[Music]
I would suspect has been designed for
um
have we got a sign off that it's
sufficient for
261 was it and
um
third one and that comes to the point
that's just been raised really
um the the recent
sustainability
officer input
in the papers
um
so so we we need to um
we're either we've got to accept what's
been put in front of us without that
input or we need to condition that we we
want an expert
opinion
dancer to council the war boys question
and others that we know is fully
satisfactory sustainable
we certainly could
add further condition
were you minded to Grant permission to
require
tree protection
methods to be further agreed the good
thing is that you can see from the video
that I took yesterday of the existing
hedge adjacent to phase one
still
intact and the piece that had to be
removed to make way for the compound
access temporary
briefly planted but I agree with you the
last thing we want is anything to
accidentally happen to any of that
Pedro because that's essentially what's
hiding the development and retaining the
character Middle Lane so I think we
should we should add further conditions
to require the method of protection to
be agreed
in turn
in terms of drainage sign off yes
Suffolk County Council Jason skilton has
looked at the figures it is capable of
accommodating the 261 dwellings
in terms of lack of a comment from
sustainability officer unfortunately we
haven't had one
in for a while and I'm sure the
administration is doing all sorts to to
rectify that but
in terms of that before
Phil perhaps
sure I should be saying that to the
chief but we'll find out later
um
in terms of
sustainability officers what we have
done is we looked at the submitted
material and it far exceeds anything
that we've had before so in crude terms
it reaches a new bar and that to us was
significant
for that matter
thank you chairman yes yes and I take no
offense from what Mr Pierce has said um
we have made arrangements for external
consultancy advice in the matter of
sustainability
a short-term basis so that is available
to us now but literally we've only got
to got through procurement through last
week so that's very much now in hand and
available we obviously need to be
comfortable that the advice we're
getting makes sense and is cogent sorry
so so you so I think you are you can you
can appropriately allow that to be
reviewed
advisors have been used by other
authorities with confidence as it's a
recommendation to us
um of their you know professional
Bonafide so I think we'd be fairly
confident we can take that away as
officers
to give you a committee some confidence
that this is being looked at not just by
planning officers thank you
thank you um and councilor hardingham
I note that the option for
for purchases to specify PV to be
installed it would be very cheap at the
build stage to require ducting to be
installed so that PV
P to only have is
extraordinarily difficult to install p
without that ducting
that may be something that you want to
ask Lyndon about and they may or may not
say they might be able to accommodate
that as a
as a an element in the build
to help reduce the cost of retrofitting
worthy option not taken up on purchasing
councilor Penny did I see your hand go
off
yes I just just a question about the
design of the houses themselves although
this might be a better question for Lind
and the dis distribution of green spaces
I note that they're all around the
borders of the development Zone
but um has has any consideration been
given to that concerning the design of
the houses with with respect to the
cooling element
and resilience as we're as with climate
change we're expecting temp temperatures
to increase
and a lot of developments have been
experiencing problems with houses
overheating
extreme weather
by all means ask Minden that question
but in terms of this layout because the
amount of open space around the margins
far exceeds the normal 10 percent that
we would require
the scope for having open space within
the development was limited and we have
secured
some but it isn't it isn't the central
design
because ordinarily we might expect to
create a large New Village green and
half around it it is the point you make
is a
good one and
then that sounds
because you're right as planners when
we're looking at layouts now we have to
think about being able to provide areas
of of shade so that people can can at
least get out of the and how Hell
enjoy open space in different ways and
perhaps have water elements and all
sorts of things
because this actual site dates back to
permission well an application in the
outline was 2016. a lot of that design
discussions all had already occurred but
in terms of the new Direction I think it
is something that we must Embrace and
it's definitely I'll show the chief
planning officer is already thinking
about
design
elements I think we all as planners need
to think again about our approach to
layouts and I'm sure we'd quite welcome
any thoughts that you may wish to give
us because you are right
being on the books for so long that we
haven't been able to incorporate those
those new ideas
okay thank you
um one more question and Council
the very quick one um I was just asked
oh there's an uplift I think in the
money going to this school and I just
wondered if there are any sort of timing
or trigger points basically will the
funding arrive before the extra children
there will be trigger points and they'll
be set out in the
um
agreement
but what the county did was forward fund
a lot of their expenditure so what we're
actually doing now is almost recovering
some of that
you'd raised the question earlier about
three
I might have been hallucinating then
well somebody did perhaps it was the
parish but what I would say is the
County Council have already thought
about that and some of those
contributions will be towards
sort of
right if we can now uh move on
um
uh
to invite the public speakers to address
the committee and we have Julian West
and Vicki Waples from Thurston Parish
Council and you'll have your three
minutes
um thank you very much if you'd like to
begin
thank you good morning everybody
over the last five years and for at
least next five years Thurston will be
undergoing unprecedented levels of
development
currently in total first and other
plumbing permissions in place for over
1250 new homes
minimal highways mitigation is in place
for these new properties which extends
in the main to Junction improvements yet
to be implemented including the crossing
at Norton Road Junction which money is
already available
this application brings no additional
commercial retail community space or
more importantly Health Facilities to
Thurston outside of the mandatory Green
Space unlimited play area provision on
the site to support the massive
uplifting population as indicated
the application fails to Accord with the
NDP and deliver Community facilities
that are needed within the village I.E a
leap Skate Park Community growing spaces
Etc
the division of two dog bins and Parish
Council notice board is hardly regarded
as a significant Community aspirations
merely throwing s106 monies at these
issues as indicated this application is
not a solution
no solution has been provided to solve
the safety issue relating to the railway
station Crossing even if Network rail
does come up with a viable solution
after having spent 100K in chill money
on a feasibility study they have
absolutely no money in the pot to
implement anything
the use of mover technology for the
Bunbury arms Junction is only necessary
to mitigate the additional vehicle
movements from this site signalization
works are already to be funded in the
first and five which has already
explained
increasing the number of dwellings on
this development over and above are
currently approved will have a further
negative effect on traffic flows and
therefore air quality and the
achievement and measures to support
these council's Declaration of a climate
emergency
not only will the traffic be increased
at pinch point in the village but an
increase in numbers at the location
where young persons are actively
accessing the highway Network system
should be challenged on all levels
furthermore the revised layout of the
properties is a prime example of how not
to carry out spatial organization as
indicated in the first and neighborhood
plan
the parish council does not agree with
the proposed development for delivers
good design given its location on the
edge of the rural Village that's still
an urban density are more applicable to
the edge of a town as opposed to the
countryside
the latest officer report notes that the
County Council the council currently has
a 10.8 year land Supply therefore there
is no demonstrable need for this
increase in housing numbers to be
approved
Thurston Parish Council urges the
committee to reject this application
today this is a prime example of a
greedy developer trying to maximize its
return at expense of good design
appropriate for the village of Thurston
should this application be approved
first of all we'll end up with yet more
additional new homes that nobody wants
and no longer required to meet their
development targets and will not have
the required solutions to the
infrastructure divisions to support it
thank you
um
Council
councilor Mathison
um yeah I think the the provision of a
public EV charging Point public
um is is I think that's been included to
meet one of your policies
um have you got as far as
um what capacity speed whatever
um you think ought to be provided
um
as a public charging point is I think
that's one of the things that we're just
starting to understand that there's
there's a lot of different ones
uh I don't have the technical advice on
that no but we are at the process of
putting some in down at the Cavendish
Hall of a new green Center and they are
they are they will have fast charging
points but the technical side of what
this public one's going to be I I don't
know
something or other that we want to
retain control of getting the right ones
um
if we get them if only it was that
simple if only all the car manufacturers
could do the same thing it would it
would help but interesting point but
maybe getting into a bit of technicality
any other questions of the parish
council
uh thank you very much
um Mr West and uh and Mrs White Horse
um we don't have an objector or a
supporter wishing to speak uh we do have
the applicant Hannah short if you'd like
to have your three minutes thank you
good morning my name is Hannah Shaw I'm
a senior planning manager for the
applicant Lyndon Thurston LLP Park
history group this application has been
subject to extensive collaboration over
some three and a half years between
ourselves and your officers to reach the
scheme for you today and we are pleased
to have their recommendation for
approval as members are aware this
application for 112 dwellings plus nine
self-build plots represent a re
represents a replan of the fun phase of
developments include an additional 61
dwellings above those approved by the
original planning permission
this is cheap through efficient use of
the established development Parcels with
no encroachment on the open space
the principle of development on the site
was established and approved by the
outline plan of commission granted in
2018. the site Falls inside the
settlement boundary and is identified
for development in the neighborhood plan
key statutory consultees including
County highways the lead local flood
Authority Heritage and ecology officers
have confirmed their objections to
proposals
the open market housing mix is weighted
much more towards smaller two and three
bedroom homes including Bungalows when
compared with the approved Reserve
matters scheme for this part of the site
this will provide greater opportunities
both for people people getting on the
housing ladder and those wishing to
downsize and is in accordance with
paragraph 5.12 of the neighborhood plan
and policy 2B
all edges of the layout facing the
countryside are of lower density
including the self-build plots
there are currently around 690
applicants on the council's housing
register our proposals include 43
affordable homes representing an uplift
of 21 and includes eight wheelchair
adaptable bungalows
the affordable housing mix has been
agreed with council's housing officer
our sustainability proposals go far
beyond any standards required by
building regulations or planning policy
if approved all dwellings will be heated
by air source heat pumps there will be
no gas Network installed to this part of
the site
combined with high levels of insulation
carbon emissions will be reduced by 58
beyond the requirements of current
building regulations
our proposal to provide PB panels to all
affordable homes are standards should go
a considerable way towards relieving
fuel poverty we will provide purchases
of open market homes with the
opportunity to purchase PV panels
to further future proof the development
electric vehicle charging points will be
provided to all homes plus a public
charging Point within the development
finally if approved the application
would secure a comprehensive package of
additional section 106 benefits these
include the installation by Vestry of
new tiger Crossing in either station
Hill or Barton Road a cycleway extension
along the frontage of Thurston Primary
School contributions towards education
Community facilities and the
installation of mover technology at
Bunbury Arms Road Junction
to conclude we hope members look
favorably upon the significant steps
taken to ensure this application is not
just acceptable but represents a
flagship in sustainable future-proof
development by a national house Builder
thank you for your time
thank you are there any questions from
members to the agent
I'm going to go for councilor War boys
first this time because councilor
Mathison keeps putting his hand up first
so let's give Council wall by I think I
saw councilor Elkin as well councilman
and I do have a question of my own thank
you
thank you chair uh yeah I think I've
already flagged my question
um you mentioned carbon emissions
reduced by 58 I think that's where we
get the exceeding building regs uh how
does that translate into energy
performance certificates uh someone
who's going to purchase one of these
houses
I don't know but
that that level of betterment would not
normally be achieved on any other
development we would meet building Rigs
and that that would be sufficient
um we've recognized here that we need to
go far beyond
um so we've tried to get way ahead of
the curve by by providing the source
heat pumps the PV
um and and that's in addition to our
sort of usual levels of insulation
thank you um thank you did you want to
come back Council what was that is that
okay
um well yes I will I'll accept that as
an answer we haven't got that
information it's just that
you know this is a lifetime purchase for
people and that's the thing people will
compare that house with with other
houses on the market and
and their perspective cost to them thank
you
Mr Pierce would like to come back
briefly
Chancellor War boys that maybe for us to
to know because I'm conscious that I
didn't have the answer and I feel as as
advisor I ought to so it may be
something through the chief planning
officer that we ensure that in future
when we have these we get the the
so that we're not talking wildly about
percentages but we do have some facts to
put to it so if
the mood of the community
in future we will ensure that we
drill down to that level of detail and
reports
councilor okin
thank you I've got two questions the
first one in our notes in section
3.115 you had a revised energy statement
made by Consultants which said that
amongst other things you were going to
consider how to mitigate against
overheating through thermal mass and
looking at solar gain but it didn't go
into any detail and I just I just
wondered how that was going to be
achieved
yeah so um there's been um quite a
recent news building regulation come out
part though which concerns overheating
um it's quite closely linked with part
L1 which is conservation of fuel and
power and hence the building fabric the
insulation plays a big part in that
um now our standard
um
thermal efficiency levels of the
building fabric I.E walls the roof the
floors
um I'll be on the minimum requirements
set by building regulations so that
helps both the energy conservation
um and the the heat performance of the
home an additional thing
um to combat overheating is that we now
have an enhanced glazing specification
to reflect the energy from from the sun
we also now have to have larger openable
areas so that when if a home is feeling
like it's overheating you can open the
window and quickly let that heat out so
that's something that's all all quite
finely balanced and there's calculations
done by our energy assessors to
demonstrate that each home meets those
standards
to combat overheating
doesn't currently have things like sort
of solar shading over windows with their
south facing and things like that
no no not not
Curry and the other very quick one I
heard us talking about play space and
some of the concerns of the parish
council about lack of provision for
older children sort of more Adventure
style play making sure they're still the
same areas for play and provision for
children with disabilities particularly
given that there are quite a few adapted
Bungalows and things like that on
potentially on the site is that
something that you could
consider looking at
yeah certainly
um we're as part of the phase two
approval we're just getting some
meetings set up with the parish council
some of liaison meetings
um we would be content to have a
condition for the play area details to
be approved
um and we would be happy to discuss that
with the parish council and to look at
provision
for inclusion for all
so that could include disability access
and also the sort of more Woodland style
kind of Adventure Playground it would
yeah thank
you thank you uh thank you councilor
Matheson
thank you um you've you will have heard
my question earlier about the
um Market housing Bungalow
um that some of the um some of those
should be M4 well I suggest that all the
Bungalows should be m42
standard and um that a couple of them
and are you prepared to
um negotiate with the officers to
work those out in detail
um so those bungalows
[Music]
but they haven't been designed
specifically as wheelchair adaptable
Bungalows however I do believe the
internal layouts would would certainly
be adaptable with some tweaks shall we
say
so you'd accept a condition
um that asked for that to be done
uh yes
uh thank you um if I might ask a
question of my own as a as a regular
cyclist I often cycle through Thurston
on my way to Berry
and that crossroads with not where
Norton Road meets um what I think is
Barton Road whichever the first one you
come to where the tiger Crossings uh may
or may not be provided now you very
um uh you have I believe offered to
provide one of those tiger cross
Crossings should the gladman appeal not
bring them to enter fruition but that
particular Crossroads if you are trying
to get from the Norton direction to the
high school one Crossing is not going to
be worth it so I just wonder whether
there was any scope that should the
gladman appeal fail
are you in any position that you could
provide both of them thank you
and yeah I think subject to further
discussions with highways um
in principle yes we could look to
provide both of those Crossings
is that something that we can we can put
into any
um condition or section 106. I'm just
asking the officer here
could incorporate that into the
106 yes and then what you we would have
that Clause that if they're not provided
by whatever then but you may also then
want to think about what happens if
Glenn do provide those facilities
do you want to be able to use that type
of Crossing somewhere else in the
village but I have discussed it
with Suffolk County and in principle
they are
very keen to see both Crossings provided
but they wouldn't necessarily want all
the other pieces that Gladwin were
providing about race tables and things
because they're not essential to the
safety element so I'm six would be my
suggestion chair rather than the
condition and would that be possible for
us to add that into whatever
our determination that there is some
scope for for negotiating with Lyndon
about providing both of them and should
they not need to be provided by by
linden that those funds can be used for
something else within the village of
Thurston is that what we what we need to
need to be doing
it is but if there's an element to think
about because Linden originally offered
one tiger Crossing and it was either
going to be in on station Hill or on the
Norton Road
if as I think has just happened Linden
have now offered to provide a second
Crossing if Gladden didn't happen
question then is
gladman did provide them
should we then only ask for one of those
Crossings as the as the default
it's not position but that's something
that's something that we can just say
that would be up to officers to
um deal with them section 106. they can
but it might be then I say well I only
think one would be reasonable if you
think you want both you should tell me
and then that's what I shall seek to
right okay thank you when we get there
does anyone else have any questions of
the applicants
right um so we we now need to call on uh
Council Davis for his Ward member
um comment I'm just hoping that Alicia
has got him set up and he should appear
on the screen
uh
good morning councilor Davis
morning chair we can hear you
functioning
brilliant if you'd like to um make your
representation thank you
yeah I will attempt to be brief it was
good to see Sam Harvey give us update on
the Bunbury arms Junctions
and confirm that the previous
s-106 payments actually cover the costs
clearly no date was given and uh
we urgently need those those changes
implemented for our existing community
as we all know we have a 10-year land
Supply so
why do we need this uplift in house
numbers
these developer clearly is working very
hard at the moment to persuade us that
it's a really good idea
um so far I understand that Gamers news
that
this idea
of this developers been involved in
working with our officers since 2016 I
think I heard
I guess you'll correct me if my hearing
is dodgy
um
anyway
so far they have had little or no
Communications with our Parish Council
and again it's heartwarming to hear that
they subsequently will look to
participate in
listening to the views of our community
and the provisions that we need
as we move forward
as a major service center
uh we have a railway station which as we
all know has a barrow Crossing which
means the significant safety hazards and
again our Parish Council is clearly
explained the
frustration that
with ever increasing numbers of people
using it and if ever more houses those
risks only get higher
and
again there's no provision for
the
Network rail to actually make it a safe
Crossing
I recognize the hard work that our
officers are put in in
coming up with
many offers from this this applicant
however the
one thing is for sure the size of the
site geographically has not increased
even though it's fit into three phases
and we have this uplift of 51 dwellings
therefore increasing the density
which is counter to our rural Village
and uh
like to observe that in our recent
planning training when asked the
question of our officers
if you have an outline planning
application that states a number of
dwellings cannot subsequently be
increased then a good number of them
answered clearly no
so
might understand why the developer and
our officers are working hard to come up
with a package to persuade
our community that this increase
in dwellings above and beyond the
outline planning
which is granted is a good thing
the lack of involvement from our
community in putting forward
representation I think
confirms how our communities lack of
faith and belief in the planning process
that they've experienced there's no
reflection on yourself sitting there
today but a consequence of the
long-standing experience
so
I would like to
confirm that I fully support what the
parish council has just explained and
that I think we should refuse this
application of an uplift in numbers
thank you
uh thank you
um do we have any questions of the ward
member
um we we've not had anything just to
confirm we've not had anything from uh
councilor Bradbury
uh thank you councilor Davis
um
for your contribution now we have been
going for a couple of hours
and we don't normally want to take a
break at this sort of stage because
you're not allowed to talk about the
case if you leave the room but I think
for the um for the benefit of everybody
we just need a five minute Comfort break
but please members do not uh talk about
the application whilst you're out of the
room thank you
move up to debate on this item and it
looks like Council of War boys is raring
to go first oh
sorry Chet could I just ask a question
first just to clarify something
in my mind
um
the neighborhood plan has identified
this this site for development and
there's a an allocated number of houses
on that site
uh similarly our emerging local plant no
will as a site designate in a designated
number of houses with that site how
advisory is that number
associated with that site is it is it a
very definitive number or is it just
advisor and it's and there's no real
firm linkage between the two
what does I understand that the the
number is not a ceiling but maybe the
planning officers can
um have make it something else maybe a
Gemma
yeah I'm happy to
um I mean obviously jlp wise we're only
on part one we are not at part two and
allocation is yet so we can't
the part two anyway we'd have to give
some weight to part one as it progresses
in terms of allocations and numbers they
do not have to be definitive I am aware
of other cases where we have gone above
the number I'm not sure we've ever gone
under in my recollection but
um I think we have gone over the number
allocated on the site so yes potentially
that is
open to us to consider and equally we'd
have to consider all of the impacts that
came with those extra numbers if that
was something we're looking at
thank you thanks
um so
um is there anyone who would like to
start the uh debate on this item
councilor Mathison I will if nobody else
will
um yeah I mean I think just just
the initial observation and
common sense of it all and we later on
struggled struggle to get into the
detail but
um that you know we know that there's
this very large number of houses already
being built in Thurston and we know
there are a number of
travel constraints let's call them uh
primarily the the the road schemes which
you know County have said is
satisfactory and it'll be okay with this
number as well etc etc but we're faced
with the fact that they're not getting
delivered and the same thing is is the
case with with the with the railway
Crossing situation where we're
it's it's not even
you know you can't see the light at the
end of the tunnel so to speak in the
delivery of of safety there and
um
and that you know I look at all that and
I say well
you know the arguments about density and
this site and within the setup boundary
and all the rest of it yeah ultimately
it makes sense to build
build these houses there but you know I
I feel I want to put a huge trigger
point in which would mean that they
would not be built
preferably any of them built for quite a
long time until some of these problems
have been solved and that's my kind of
Common Sense place with it all at the
moment
councilor hadingham
thank you I completely um
you know understand where John's coming
from like you know I'm sure I can't
remember if he was there at the needy
Market when the the less than five came
up and it was a terribly depressing day
in the history of planning I feel but um
and
however
you know this you know
this this you know the sustainability
and um energy statements on this look
good the density is um
you know what I could say there's the
smaller the the increase of smaller
units rather than just big old five
bedroom executive homes which is not
always what's needed although they might
look nice
um
the side does already have planning
permission I'm worried like I say I'm
not you know hugely keen on this but um
but I'm just thinking we will sort of
struggle I feel I fear we will struggle
to um to find reasons to turn it down at
the moment
uh thank you uh Council Lawrence
I find it hard uh to almost ignore the
wishes of the parish council and the
submissions that they have made
um these people are locals of the area
living with it day in day out and who
sit remotely in a chamber like this and
pass judgment
um with in my view little regard to
their wishes and desires
seems a little bit strong I'd also got
the second point I'd like to make is
that
I'm uncomfortable with a situation where
an applicant applies
for a certain number of homes that
outline planning permission
and then decides at a later date they're
able to increase it by a 25 percent
I sit uncomfortably with that as a
precedent setting for other
developers in the future
um
I understand it's obviously not grounds
for refusal but it's principle and
direction I'm uncomfortable for that as
a committee
thank you um anybody else wish to say
anything
um
Council of War boys is that your hand
going up yes yeah it's uh
it's not an easy I don't think this is
an easy one to sort of say yes or no to
I I think the Linden homes has
definitely sort of made a good case the
of moving in the right direction with
regards to Energy Efficiency
um and there's there are carrots dangled
for the community in terms of you know
half a million
pounds of seal in section 106
um
and the remaining opens
spaces we sort of transfer to the
community in perpetuity which means that
that that this is the end of that
development as far as I can make out
um looking at the initial layouts it was
obviously a
big space there that could be developed
at some time in the future so whether
that would be
and that could be anticipated in the
future
um
I am reluctant to sort of undermine the
parish council and its neighborhood plan
um
there's a point there that there's no
additional
retail spaces or employment spaces
coming forward and I think um as if the
case officer said you know we have moved
forward in terms of how we look at
how we look at developing spaces in
terms of the housing and the provision
for the people are going to live there
um
but
and that sets the sort of argument going
in my head that should we look at
previous development as set in the
precedent in terms of how we look at
a new development
and whether it's sort of in keeping with
the character of the The Villages itself
um
that being said I'm finding it difficult
to find sort of anything really very
very concrete and I can say this
development should be refused
thank you um I think did you want to
come back and say something
very quickly I may have misunderstood
you Council of War boys but the open
space will not be transferred
into the public
domain it will remain with Linden
and manage through management company
but I'm suggesting in the section 106
agreement is that Linden
commit themselves to keeping that as
open space in perpetuity which would
then give the community the certainty
that they couldn't come back
it will remain in their ownership as it
stands but the 106 will safeguard that
for
that as open space
thank you for clarifying that yes I
think I I sort of put it together wrong
well
um councilor penny
just in regards to con continuity of
character
I a personal opinion probably is that
there are a lot of urban style
developments being built in the
countryside
and
I understand the logic that
is continuity of character to keep on
building the same style of
some has existed before but like whether
this is
whether this is the right direction or
whether you whether we continue to have
Urban style building in the countryside
because that that is what is there
before and we're building on that is
that a good idea
not only this development so it's a
personal opinion
Urban style homes in the countryside
it may be your opinion but it may be
shared by a lot of us as
planners and I think the answer might be
to develop our own design guidance in
in terms of
different sorts of character development
in different locations
but I think I think I'm being political
with a big or a small p
with the drive to deliver
large housing numbers
it almost
demands that we get larger Estates and
it's very hard to design a large estate
to look like it should have been in the
countryside because as you know villages
grew organically piece by piece not by
50 100 150 200
in one go
um
I'm hoping that once we get the jail P
part one in we might be able to turn
some of our thinking towards design
thinking and start to re-examine how we
approach development in the rural area
moment we are where we
we are I think there is probably a
strong case to have a different approach
in the countryside where we're not at
hundreds of houses if that's going to be
the way forward it doesn't answer your
question here and now but it is
it is something that outside of this
forum we do need to have that debate I
think it may have been a sort of
hypothetical question because and we are
where we are we can't move this
application forward
um if no one else is raring to put their
hands up maybe I'll just say what I
think and I think it's it's a very
difficult case because
um much as we thought there were going
to be 200 homes on this plot and we
didn't like that and I do remember that
fateful day
in the council chamber in Needham Market
um and I do remember how I voted on
those applications and and I think it
it's it's
wrong that all of that development is
now 75 occupied and we've still seen
none of the highway improvements and
we've seen nothing at the railway
station which was my biggest concern for
somebody who wants public transport to
be as accessible as possible
and network rail are just an impossible
body to deal with and I don't know how
we can expediate them to get on with
things but that certainly needs to be
addressed and here we are proposing an
extra 61 houses on top of those first
and five which all got permission on one
day
but I think Lyndon have tried hard to
give us a package which looks acceptable
because they've got these super duper
energy performance they're offering
um more than probably as required of
them in terms of funding for more even
more Highway stuff but how do we know if
it's ever going to get done
um that is a problem
um
so I think it's a really hard decision
to make we are generating a bigger a
higher density housing but I'm not sure
high density housing is bad per se
because as someone else has already
mentioned it means you get a higher
proportion of smaller properties and
that's what we always want we don't want
a bunch of executive four bed homes with
three bathrooms we want some nice
ordinary houses for for people who can't
afford executive homes so and this this
development is putting more of those
smaller properties on the market I think
it's a shame that the Bungalows which
are going to be disabled access are all
affordable
and I think we do need to consider
making sure that we have disabled access
on Market homes as well as affordable
homes and I'm not sure if that can be
dealt with now because that's probably
done and dusted
um I think it's a really difficult
decision to make because we all hear
what the parish council have said and
and they put an awful lot of work into
their neighborhood plan it was one of
the first ones to be adopted
um and they have suffered an awful lot
of development already
um but as other people have said I'm not
sure we've got enough of a good reason
to say no
um but I'll hopefully um the people
haven't yet spoken will say their
opinion and we can actually move forward
with this decision um so I think
councilor hardingham
yes
um I would take note of the increased
energy performance
um
this this offers
probably offers us
an opportunity to to push the standards
of having going forward in in the
district
and to and to look at pushing these
energy standards onto future
developments
There's an opportunity there in that
respect
it's a minor point but if we were to
Grant permission I would like to require
the developer to include adapting to
future-proof the houses for PV
installation in the future that wouldn't
cost them very much
thank you Council Lawrence did you want
to come back
I would just like to say I take note of
the improved insulation and
air source heat pumps and everything
else but whether we accept or refuse
this application today doesn't really
matter we can still insist on those on
future developments anyway so I don't
think it's relevant to the decision of a
yes or no today
my concern is that we've got a 10.8 year
Housing Bank already there's going to be
no Justified requirement as to why this
should be increased by another 200
residents at this
thank you
anybody else wish to speak
councilor Matheson yeah the the um yeah
I think chair that just the um the M4
two and three situation I did persuade
the agent to agree that they would
negotiate to provide those on the um on
the market
sale
um Bungalows as well and I was hoping
that if we do get to the point of
um approving this that we'd be putting
that is in a conditional Mr piercing
started his head I'm hoping that the the
area planning manager is making a note
of all of these things we want to add
um I've been making like this as well
actually not not good ones but still
um but I think my you know coming back
to what I said to begin with
um
you know I I'm looking at
offices to help me with trigger points
now I I I was very surprised when um the
case officer said that the
um
this uh this 61 houses was going to make
the difference with the with the um the
so-called mover technology at the
Bunbury arms because although I wasn't
on the the outline of those five in the
first place
as others were
um I've seen some of the reserved
matters debates
um subsequently
um and and I certainly remember you know
lengthy explanations of what this this
mover technology would do at the Bunbury
arms
um in terms of smoothing the flow and
easing the the massive congestion
congestion that you get there at the
moment
of fact
um
it's
in my understanding it doesn't need this
50 000 quid for it to be delivered
therefore we should be able to
make that a requirement
that the the houses are not
built
of this version of the with the extra 61
included is not built and until that
technology is installed and working
the Bunbury arms and officers can help
me about that now what's what's even
more difficult is how you define what is
an a workable practical
trigger point with the station because
you know being well familiar with it
um it it is quite a tough
problem which would lead some you know
epically large amounts of money to solve
it unfortunately and
um
so to to hold this back on the basis of
a until there is
um you know satisfactory level access to
both sides of the Railway
Etc is um is that's a very
a very tall order so I don't know what
how you feel about the the first one the
Bunbury arms situation
in terms of the move of Technology
you're right I can remember presenting
how mover worked
and what it would deliver but that was
associated with the gladman
vacation it was it's only the gladman
and um
as we refuse that if they aren't
successful in appeal we don't get that
money for that technology that wasn't
included in the original scheme so
put your mic on
sorry what else are we have we already
going to get at the Bunbury arms in
relation to all the stuff that has got
permission has been and it has been
built since you will get signalization
of each arm the forearms you'll get some
um adjustment to the highway geometry
with flared
slips off of the Thurston Road onto the
a134 but the technology that would come
with the traffic lights is simply it's
pre-programmed
so it won't be able to adapt to changing
traffic now in terms of is there a
suitable trigger I think it would be
reasonable for me to say that we
couldn't actually trigger
61 extra units
or tie it to either delivery of remover
or improvements to the station the
station works at the moment it may not
be entirely safe but it is the station
it does work you have approved nearly a
thousand dwellings
on the basis that at some point we might
be able to sort out the platform issue
in Thurston I am involved in the
discussions with network rail I know
that work is ongoing I know that we have
had Network rail in Roundtable meetings
it's previously it's been very difficult
to get hold of them we are now actively
involved in those discussions they've
been led by Christine Thurlow who's our
infrastructure manager and has access to
to seal funding but in terms of could we
reasonably restrict
this development
on the basis if you want triggers tied
to the station works I would say that
would be unreasonable
be achieved because we probably have the
Dilemma of which 61 dwellings of the 61
that you're going to hold back from is
that reasonable I don't think it's
it is workable or reasonable in the
sense of
planning Authority having to be
reasonable in terms of its decision
making
yeah thank you I mean I think I yeah I
accept
grudgingly the the
station you know the unreasonable etc
etc and it's slightly encouraging to
hear that that there is a discussion
where um you know that it's been so
difficult as the chair has said
um so could we could we put the trigger
the the Bunbury
Tech not the
the physical Works actually including
the traffic lights etc etc etc that that
is in place
for
these houses are built
and then and then when and then they're
going to go ahead and give us the 50 000
but to actually hold up until it gets
done and we've heard from from San
Harvey earlier that that um you know
that is some distance away still
um quite a large distance away probably
in years rather than months
um can we do that
I would suggest
because the Third
the third have already paid
the money they were required to pay to
facilitate the Bunbury arms
improvements it isn't it isn't the
developers let's say fault but those
Works haven't happened they paid their
money in the full expectation that those
Works would be undertaken
this I I've spotted councilor War boys
arm got but can I just ask you said that
the Mover technology was
um
um was one of the
contributions should the gladman get
approval so if that that we know that's
going through appeal now if that does
get
um approval is that 50 000 for the move
of Technology still in in the bundle and
if gladman does get approved and
contributes their 50 000 for the Mover
technology can we still have the 50 000
from Linden to do something else
I would argue yes
you could require that 50 000 to go
towards those improvements themselves or
other Highway improvements Within
thirsty and that could be written into
the exception into the 106 and that may
provide you with a mechanism for getting
something
out of it in terms of another if that
helps the county move it forward because
they've got the equivalent funding
but it it can be done and it could be
done if that's the will of the committee
thank you councilor War boys
yes it's just a continuous kind of
continuation of um what was just
can we set the bar a bit lower and
um
there's two
Thai Crossings
which need to be completed as well one
which is associated with the
the um
the gladman development and we heard in
a previous meeting and that's been
stalled because of a lack of funds and
the costs are increasing I could we sort
of have at least a pedestrian Crossings
actually sort of
um as trigger points if you like for
this development
I just want to be sure in my own mind
that
Linden put those Crossings in early
and gladman were successful and they
paid in there when
we could use the money they were going
to put towards these two Crossings for
something else in Thurston
but so can I just ask when when
something goes to appeal
and presumably should it get permission
does the section 106 agreement still get
negotiated by our officers here or does
the um inspector deal with that the
inspector was presented with
the 106. so at the inquiry that that
document formed part of the discussion
it has already been worked up and were
there any trigger points on gladman
should they get approval to produce
those tiger Crossings in terms of
occupation I
deal with that so I don't know but I'm
just thinking the backstop might be
the 106 requires
Linden
Crossings in
as soon as
we hear about and if we know that Lyndon
sorry if we know the Clubman we're not
successful Lyndon put them in
early
if gladman are successful then that
money goes towards something else in
first so that way let's say the decision
comes out in the next two months we will
know which of those options to trigger
in which case the 106 can pick that up
but if but if there's no trigger point
on on gladman
they could build the whole of their
development and and Linden might be half
occupied and we still haven't got tiger
Crossings that's why I'm suggesting
that the trigger is once we know what
happens to the gladman
appeal
and if they lose Lyndon then put them in
ASAP if gladman win
we then use that equivalent money
somewhere else in Thurston so it might
mean a delay of two months or so but it
might take us that long to negotiate
that the 106 because we haven't done
that work in advance
uh councilor Penny I think had his hand
up next
yeah so I was just going to uh remind us
that this is a two a two-part
application
um there's the full permission for 112
dwellings and nine for outline
permission on the self builds
I'm just wondering what the effect might
be were we to
say approve
the 112 development but
um refuse the outline planning
on the nine self builds how might that
if I think the development going
forwards and any attached conditions
um part of the as I understand it part
of the
um outline that's already got the 200
includes some self-builds
so
if that was the case there's still
outline permission for nine self builds
but maybe I'm wrong
it's an interesting
option
see where you're coming from
unfortunately because those already
exist in an earlier permission I don't
think we'd have any chances appeal to be
able to defend that
it would be a split decision which is
awkward
Gemma did you want to come in about
anything
I was merely contemplating the gladman
versus Linden Order of Things
um my very slight concern was if gladman
failed to implement their consent that
would die without London having been
made to implement them potentially I
think you could work around that with
wording and I think the percentage
chance of something not delivering on a
consent of that size would
so I think I was just mentally going
through the the Hoops of that one just
thinking of the alternative problems
that we might encounter if we went that
way so I think we could work yeah
Elkin
we like everyone else I'm just really
told Vicky
because we're considering
this on its merits it doesn't matter
whether we we like it but um we have to
look at it on its merits and there's
some benefits of being more dense we're
taking less land from other places for
example
um it's got more affordable housing good
environmental standards but it's
obviously clearly not wanted by the
community and the parish council I've
been very clear about that
um so I was just wondering in terms of
fairness it would seem fair for the
developer if they're asking
essentially for more to to offer more to
the community in terms of
um
I can't remember the um the gentleman
who spoke mentioned that the parish
council had greater Ambitions than you
know a noticeable in a couple of dog
bins in terms of what the site was was
offering to the community and
and whether there are things that we can
do with conditions or anything else to
make sure that the the community gets as
much as as possible of what they would
like to see if if Lyndon get more of of
what they would like on the site whether
that's play space or you know any other
aspects that have been discussed
come in Vincent thank you chair the the
offer in terms of the 106 also includes
58 000 pounds towards community
facilities so that is quite wide ranging
I'm hoping we're members to approve it
that and it's kind of something
councilor Mathison said off somebody
said about how the parish had not been
engaged by linden in the past
um
I have great hopes for the parish
liaison scheme if it is working
elsewhere not just in the
Linden is genuine
about wanting that to work then there
will be
monthly meetings between the two and I'm
hoping that will build a relationship
that does allow perhaps the district or
invest money or site with lyndon's
blessing I can't guarantee it but we
found it has been a good way on other
sites to break that sort of
non-communication deadlock and actually
get people talking we found it does
produce results because
once you're in the room monthly it's
very difficult to keep saying no to
things
58 000 would come to The District in the
first place
but we're more than happy to discuss
that with Thurston around how that's
spent so yeah I as as my Parish has got
a liaison group with one of the
developers but of course every company
will treat it differently and how how
one developer behaves isn't necessarily
going to be the same for everybody but
but yeah we we did have a meeting and
and we've put some proposals forward and
we'll yet to see if they happen but
there you go we are meeting with them
um right does anybody else uh cancel the
war boys
I I think I was going to Across the
bullet and I think I'm going to propose
that we accept this
uh proposal
I
I I've got a little phrase here that are
the two tiger Crossings are there
swinging argument I mean for me they are
I've brought it up before that we've
identified safety
issues with regards to these crosses
they do need to be
brought forward as quickly as possible
so if we can do that through this
development which
is good against the neighborhood plan
but we
've been advised that the numbers and
the space is allocated
is is flexible it is it is a larger
increase
but Lyndon a
brought forward
proposals that include improve the
Energy Efficiency so the build is a
substantial contributions the community
um
and I think it's a good proposal I'm yes
there are design considerations and
ideas have moved on since this
development has started certainly in
terms of building materials perhaps we'd
be looking for a broader use of building
materials but the nine
self-built houses
within the site perhaps offer that kind
of opportunity for some creative and
Innovative designs coming forward and
there is a shortage I believe of
self-built opportunities Within
the district so I'm proposing with
everything that has been brought forward
which I can possibly summarize
um that we accept them thank you uh
Council War wish do we have a second uh
councilor Mathison are you going to say
I I would I would second it but I I want
to come back to the Bunbury arms and I I
mean if you just step back a moment from
this application you know the history of
of the
fairly rapid development of houses in
mid-suffolk
um has raised the head of the
improvements to infrastructure and that
applies across the whole piece and and
the you know just it's not only this but
um you know with developers are are
paying over large sums of of sale money
um on the pretext that that um
the health
facilities are going to be improved
um and that doesn't happen and um
so I'm not I'm not you know I'm gonna
press back against the officers saying
that that um you know the Bunbury the
Bunbury situation can't
um you know I can't I can't have it
of the condition that it must be
physically provided you know but that's
the point we we we're not managing to
physically provide the infrastructure
um develop you know development by
development that and that's you know
it's all about just thirsts and other
places as well and um so surely I mean
you know I can see yes they paid the
money but no
you know the infrastructure is not
provided now why can we not actually
make that
the trigger for the development to go
ahead you know what is the
is there a legal of planning argument
that says that that cannot be
well I think you can't force Linden
that to make Suffolk County council do
the work
they're different companies I mean that
maybe I'm wrong but that's how I see it
and it's exactly the same with the
network rail stuff is you've got
developments who are contributing money
towards improvements that are meant to
go to network rather Network well don't
don't deliver but you can't make the
developer make somebody else do the work
but maybe I'm wrong maybe the planning
officers might want to come
there might be a
necessarily for this
this County also has made it clear that
they are less Keen to have Highway
improvements via section 106 agreements
what they now Advocate are Highway
improvements through Section 278 of the
Highway Act
because if it's under 278 they can
require the developer to put it in
six they just get the money and they
have to put
to put it so the way forward might be
on larger schemes to have a grampian
condition that says you can't start your
development until the improvements are
in and then the developer is responsible
for putting those in and it cuts Suffolk
County Council out of the equation for
delivery
but we can't do that here because
because
it might be something you want to keep
up your sleeve for future
now I'm looking at it from the you know
from the community's point of view
the fact that money's in in the county
council's bank account doesn't help them
one iota does it
what they need is the actual
infrastructure and we must be a way of
somehow of actually ensuring that that
happens before the houses happen before
the houses are occupied
um
committee could always
Express concern that can be transferred
across to Suffolk County then
but we can do that but but it it may not
have any teeth but I think that's as
much as we can do it is an expression of
your increasing frustration that series
important infrastructure projects appear
not to be progressing at the speed you
would like and that might have a
political Dimension outside of this
Arena that is picked up
is there anyone who is prepared to
Second Council of War boys proposal
councilor hardingham
does anybody else want to make any um
any views known anyone to say anything
now that we have a proposal on the table
councilor Lauren
forgive me for my ignorance and the
working of the committee but I would
prepare to pose opposition to it what I
believe we do is we have to vote on this
proposal which has now been seconded
should that proposal fail you can then
put a second another proposal am I right
in that um so so we have a we have a
seconded motion now so we have to
progress with that you are limited to
vote how you want on that
um but should that not be
um get a majority we then have to open
up for another proposal that that I
think is how it works
councilor Mathison yeah we need a review
of all the conditions that yeah we
certainly do and I'm hoping that Gemma
has got is going to read them all out
you're going to tick them off from your
list councilor War boys and councilor
Elkin have also been making notes are
going to tick them off their list I'm
not very good at being chair here and
making note with more so I'm relying on
new people so over to you Jim thank you
chair uh yep so where I'm at at the
minute is that we're looking at
approving as the recommendation which is
on pages 99 to 100 of your papers and as
amended on pages three and four of the
table papers with additional conditions
to agree the screening to self-built
plots
um that was in the engine that while
they come forward essentially that tree
protection methods were to be agreed the
play area details were to be agreed the
PV ducting
um also scheme to be agreed on that one
uh scheme for m42 and m43 plots to be
agreed and then additional section 106
requirements were to include early
provision of both tiger Crossings and
then the Mover contribution to be used
for Highway Improvement works if the
Mover technology is previously
contributed to by other development
scheme
skate that was fairly quick rattle
through did I catch everything
there was something about some sort of
design code for the
um for the self builds
I think that's one table papers already
okay right um anyone else has made notes
is there anything missing yeah we we did
we we talked about improving the
protection of the Hedge
and and there was something there was
something else that the case officer
said that he'd recognized that he hadn't
included in the conditions I'm just
struggling to remember what that is
and
um also I've got the there was the
have we covered the cycle Crossing issue
that the chair raised
um two tiger Crossings if possible Gemma
picked that up in terms of the 106 and
we have picked up the point you you
referred to councilor Mathison is having
a wall
in the interim if the sales Bill didn't
happen and gemma's picked that up I
believe these are my first ones I put
screening rather than a wall
specifically because then we've got a
bit of
opportunity to dream provision or
something isn't it yeah I can call it
boundary provision a screening boundary
yeah I think I think the the um I I
thought my note about the self-build
seemed to relate partly to timing as
well as screening
um it was if if the self-build hasn't
happened by the time those units on the
Northern Edge
of Cavendish spew are being built a wall
has to be erected at the back rather
than the fence if in the interim
permission has been granted for the
self-health that could be offense Timber
fence because it won't be on show
set a wall facing the countryside
yes
we never built fences and walls facing
the country so the debate we had last
but I think it was brought up when the
original phase two thing came through
and I think we did question it there but
we decided it looks better than a
a
well the problem with the Hedge is that
it it's um when they then build them
what's gonna happen to the Hedge
oh which I have put a grease screening
so we could still take that conversation
away at the appropriate moment to make
sure that's agreed and then if things
change we've got that option yeah and
the LA the last one that I've got it was
I think spelling out in more detail
um that the the sustainability features
uh we're going to get the once over by
an expert
um that Mr Isabel was offering us
um yeah that is again that's on the late
papers so developers to agree with the
council itself design and sustainability
principle statement so that would be the
condition and then going forward now
that we've got sustainability provision
back in that would be the case for any
sustainability condition that would be
reviewed by our Consultants is that okay
I think that's ticked off my list
Council War boys is there anything that
hasn't been mentioned that you thought
was going to be included in the um
conditions
did you
I don't think so there was just it was
just from my understanding that the
statement that sort of the play area
will be
I can't remember the phrase but um
looked at does that include specifically
provision for children with disabilities
haven't said this explicitly but I think
Vince could probably take the wise
condition if you'd prefer it in the
recommendation I can do so yeah and can
we also have this informative whatever
we want to try whatever however strongly
we can
um put it to the county about get
getting the works done I mean is that
how is that what we do it's all we have
to put it in as an informative
um that we need to get that it would be
a separate letter to whether it's the
chief exec or something or something but
what we could do with gemma's approval
is if we draft something perhaps you as
the chair and the vice chair might just
want to give it the one time to see that
it
the tone is as you would wish you so
perhaps that's a minute rather than
action sheet okay it goes on to your
action plan or something yeah
so yeah did we with the the play
equipment I mean I guess the
the point was clear that we wanted one
or two items of of accessible
um you know there are specific and
different pieces of equipment
um that that children with
um you know Mobility needs and
difficulties can use so we're saying
that we would actually include yes
because that's something that a
disability Forum
um has asked for and they're meeting
right now as well
yep so I can tweak that point so I've
suggested uh play area details including
provision for accessible play to be
agreed so again that will give it the
scope it will come back to us to Vince
and we can agree to some of those
teenager options all of that can be
Revisited but the accessible players
specifically stated there for you
council did you want to come back on
that yeah just again it was I know it's
something that was mentioned and really
wanted by the community was provisioned
for older children so again I don't know
if it's reasonable to include that
all the teenagers I'm not sure that's
the work um
all ages all ages that's an excellent
term thanks
so play area details including provision
for accessible play and including all
ages to be agreed
is there anything else anybody wishes to
say
um before we just needed just a summary
of The Proposal and then we'll go for
the vote so can we just have a summary
of what we're going to vote on thank you
thank you chair so this is to approve as
the recommendations set out on pages 99
to 100
and as amended on pages three to four of
the table papers and then with
additional conditions to agree screening
to the boundary of self plots if not
implemented before adjacent units the
tree and hedge protection methods to be
agreed play area details including
provision for accessible play and
including all ages to be agreed PV
ducting to be agreed scheme for m42 and
m43 to be agreed and then additional
section 106 requirements to include
early provision of both tiger Crossings
and the Mover contribution to be used
for Highway Improvement works if mover
technology previously contributed to by
other development schemes
and also the the the tiger Crossings the
money if they're not if that's not
needed that's going elsewhere as well
does that need to be included there
is that already covered Vince
the committee okay uh so
um
so to include early provision of birth
type Crossings with contribution to be
used for
other Highway
works if previously implemented
well did you need that again chair as a
whole are we all right with that or does
Gemma need to read it all out again
well I think I think we can go so I will
ask the officer to conduct the
electronic vote thank you
chair members that vote is now in
progress thank you
thank you members chair that's five
votes four and three against that's
carried thank you so that that
um case is now um Opa thank you very
much uh Parish Council and um and
fitness
um now uh I'm gonna suggest we have
another 10 minute break
um now and we'll try uh bearing in mind
we don't want lunch now because we've
all got to get to elmsworld later on
this afternoon for our council meeting
so can we just take another 10 minute
Comfort break now and then we'll come
back at 22 1 12 40
um to do the second case and we'll try
and get through that to give us time for
a break
okay um we're now moving to our second
uh case uh
dc2206378 Truck East limited Violet Hill
Road Stone Market
um so I'll invite the case officer
Daniel Cameron to introduce the
application thank you
thank you chair
um yes we've got a outline application
for the reaction of up to 65 new
dwellings including the delivery of up
to 22. affordable dwelling so
um with this application members we're
looking at items of principle and we've
also got details of access and highways
improvements to consider
tells for appearance layout scale and
Landscaping with all form Reserve
matters if we were to approve the
application today a further application
of those reserved matters would need to
come forward and be made before
development commence and that come back
to members for scrutiny at the
appropriate time
and this works
there we go okay so um
you have the report in front of you and
they should also be uh
late papers and table papers in the form
of the place Services ecology response
which came through and also uh comments
from Star Market Town Council
um this is the site it is the truck East
Depot on Violet Hill Road
which runs up the edge of the site this
current three accesses onto Violet Hill
Road enjoyed by
site truck used to be on site for over
50 years and were involved in mot repair
and testing of vehicles on site
including hgvs they've now relocated to
lawn Farm business park with no net loss
of employment within the district
and then if we come slightly wider we
have children community Primary School
to the immediate North we can see edges
of the cemeteries to the north as well
of violet Hill Road Stow health
and then we have residential development
surrounding and you can just Glimpse the
edge of the recreation ground as well to
the south in that
turning to you constraints the site
itself is relatively unconstrained we
have areas of fluid zone two and three
this side in terms of immediate
constraints around the site we have a
run of TPO trees
along the other edge of violet Hill Road
none of them encroach within the site
and we've taken comments from our
arboricultural officer um
protection plan would Safeguard the
future of those TPO trees and we've got
a grade two listed building that's
Evelyn feison house which is detailed in
your report at section 10 as well
there's a number of public rights away
around the area but none that run
through our site
we do have a permissive path that runs
up and I've got images later in the
presentation for you members at runtop
this edge of the site and provides a
connection into the playing field at
Chilton Community primary school and
that provides access from Kent Road and
the adjacent uh Morton close uh Kings
Mead close development on
the sea
here
in terms of the site at present we've
got the office building
which is as currently three stories
we've got the repair buildings off to
the
two-story and then we have some smaller
outbuildings
around
um which stand at one story
um
and then when we come to the indicative
site plan we have a three to four story
flattered development at the frontage or
through a parking court and then the
remainder of the site is shown as a
detached semi detection and Terrace
dwellings
we also have closing up of two of the
existing accesses onto Violet Hill Road
we have a connectivity improvements in
terms of Crossings one on Violet Hill
Road and one on Recreation Road and I'll
show you the details of those in due
course we have integrated Suds and the
scheme as presented in indicative form
is fully compliant with uh Suffolk
guidance for parking so you have a fully
parking compliance scheme although I
would know that
we would have control over that for
Reserve matters so if members were
minded to see something
come forward that delivered a lesser
degree of parking as a parking authority
we could we could secure that and given
that we're within Star Market itself
um that may well be something that that
members want to consider
um
if I turn to the colored indicative site
plan in terms of the services and
Facilities around the site we have
primer and preschool within 200 meters
of the site we have the recreation
ground and the Leisure Center both
within 500 meters of the site
Stow health is
between 200 and 300 meters of the site
we have uh large supermarkets within 600
meters of the site and Stone Market
railway station is within 800 meters of
the site
um we've got some indicative scale just
to show you in context of the
surrounding area we have the two-story
set against the two-story on Kent Road
I've got some images later in the
presentation of that development there
and then we have three to four on the
Frontage seen against the three to four
story
development on the other side of violet
Hill Road at present we have
um 12 trips that's to and from site by
hgvs
per day
um in terms of other traffic impacts
highways are content that the impact of
the site are present in terms of other
vehicle movements would be largely the
same
you should a development of 65 dwellings
come forward on the site
we have phase one and two land
remediation plans and a full scheme for
land remediation
um considered by our colleagues in
environmental health that we can
condition and in terms of the additional
comments from
ecology at Play services
their content in terms of impact
managed by condition
here's a site in scale scene from the
other way so you've got Kent Road
top of the screen
in terms of comments received back we
have some comments regarding open space
and a desire to see an additionality of
open space come on site from our public
realm colleagues
given the proximity of the recreation
ground in the facilities that we have
there in terms of quite an expansive
play area Escape Park and Cafe it's
considered that we do have a center of
um
play with an easy walking distance of
500 meters
um
with regards to parking as I've
mentioned before we have control of that
through the reserve matter especially if
we wanted to see a a scheme that wasn't
compliant with parking guidance come
forward we might want to consider that
given sustainability criteria over the
site as a whole and those can all be
addressed within the reserve matters in
terms of console T comments we have no
objection safe from our colleagues in
Economic Development who prefer not to
lose the employment generation from the
site however within the report that's
been taken up as part of the overall
planning balance and considering the
recommendation put before
members
in terms of the section 106
um we've got a slight phasing plan there
we have uh section 106 secured for new
build primary education within Stone
Market and you build early years
education it's also noted that uh tro to
enforce some movement of parking based
on Violet Hill Road to increase
visibility is also there and we would
also be securing the affordable housing
and maintenance of open space on site
and with regards to sill we've already
had comments come forward from Partners
at Suffolk County with regards to
secondary education sixth form education
and libraries and our infrastructure
team would be circulating civil receipts
once received to colleagues in the NHS
to see if any health care expansion is
provided or is necessary as well
our survey
in terms of the accesses they're shown
on this slide so
Crossing Point implemented further down
Violet Hill Road from the site
to enable Crossing to the other side and
then also further around on Recreation
road to enable a crossing point to
access the recreation ground
and then in terms of on-street parking
Arrangements we've got some on-screen
on-street parking Bays
arrayed along this side of violet Hill
Road
The Proposal is to reallocate those and
reconsider those to enable greater
visibility displays for traffic coming
both up and down by that Hill Road as
well
in terms of site photos this is one of
the accesses into Truck East and you can
see the single story outbuildings
in the background
any further up by the hill road you can
see the two-story servicing buildings
and the three-story offices
in terms of the views up Violet Hill
Road we have an existing business which
is a sandwich shop on the corner of
recreation Road and violet Hill Road
that doesn't form part of the
application and it would be remaining on
site where members to approve this
application
further up Violet Hill Road
you can see the The Verdant hedgerows on
both sides and then also you get a good
impression of the trees have been
protected by TPO on the other side
say further up we've got the offices off
to the left
and then again those verdant trees
coming up and then just beyond this
building we get to the edge of the site
and these trees and then on the School
site
um let's just continue our way up and
you can just see the edge of the school
buildings
in the distance there
sorry slide
this is the corner of the Truckee site
so that was um
apologies that's what we've seen earlier
then we've got access in to the
flattered scheme and The Stone Market
police station on the other side of
violet Hill Road
we've got the Stow Health Center further
up Violet Hill Road
which is three three and a half stories
in height
and then as we turn around on Violet
Hill Road to head back to or down
towards
um
Stone Market
it looked clearer on my image numbers
but you can see the edges of uh
two-story Housing Development on the
other side
we carry on down you can see that
verdant character on the other side of
violet Hill Road
um who just got the corner of the three
to three and a half story flatter
development on the other side of the
road
and this is then from the other side of
the entrance traveling down towards
stowmarket
and then this is the building itself
seen in winter when we don't have the
leaf coverage on the trees so you get a
much clearer idea of the impact of that
building
this is Empire Hill Road down towards
Stone market we've got the turn to
Recreation we're just on our right there
and then turning down that access this
is the view from the bottom of Kent Road
where we have repetition of red brick
semi-detached dwellings all the way
along
and then this is the end of uh Kent Road
and the backside of
and this is the edge of the permissive
path and parents and children use that
to access
Chilton Community primary school and
that would be uh added into and joined
up as part
pose works for this development
this is wallsey close on the other side
of the back of that development we've
got a small parade of local shops
and then this is kingsmead close so the
back of the dwellings he saw two slides
ago members this is their Frontage and
you can see a small access through to
that permissive path as well
um this is the view down Recreation Road
um so we'd get crossing point in
just beyond these cars
and then this is slightly further down
and you can get access so this is the
corner into Kent Road
and that's the edge of the recreation
ground with the skate park and the play
facilities within it
the recommendation before you members is
for approval of the
Reserve map of the outline pursuant to
the reserve matters and the conditions
listed in the report
added in to the conditions
um
suggested by Place services on their
table papers response
I'll hand over to members if there's any
questions arising from the portal
presentation thank you Daniel do we have
any questions of the officer
uh Council hardingham
oh thank you Bob
what options are there to improve the
layout and design of the site between
now and detail so that would that would
seems like a very old-fashioned and
straight line layout with not much sense
of place being being given to the to the
residents
so that would all form part of the
discussions around the reserve matters
um I think anyone who is looking to come
forward with the reserve matters would
probably want to see
um you know some some Surety in terms of
what they're presenting and what they're
looking to come forward with we do offer
a pre-application service that
agents and developers do take
um make use of and we'd be able to bring
up those issues at that point when we do
have consideration of appearance and
layout and scale and Landscaping and so
we do have that we'd also have the
opportunity within the application
itself Reserve matters
two officers development of this skill
we need to come back before planning
committee for approval in any case
planning committee have given the
outline approval so even if the numbers
fail dramatically
um
negation that would still be captured so
it'd almost be that to
two opportunities effectively both for
officers to give their View and then for
members to consider and give their view
prior to determination and prior to
works commencing on site
thank you
any uh councilor Elkin
or about them
and Road access I think you said that
they were currently or there have been
12 hgv movements and everyone's happy
that that would be reduced but I did
notice there were 140 parking spaces
um so there's obviously going to be a
lot of cars on site if it comes forward
as as conceived at the moment I mean I
know cars are a lot easier to to deal
with than than big hdvs on small roads
but um
I just wondered if you could say a
little bit more about
what are the likely problems and impacts
would be a quite a big jump in in small
cars
so in terms of hdv movement
outside of the development phase if we
were to get that far we would see the HG
movements to and from the site reduce in
terms of controlling those within the
development phase we normally be seeking
a construction method statement
um
of that we'd want to want to know
routing for hgv movement we may want to
know hours of delivery so we can keep
those outside of peak hours
quite often we might look to secure
um
communication on those as well just so
they're more visible
um
in terms of
what comes forward there that could take
you know the form of updates on Facebook
sites updates on websites for
developments now as when they have
large-scale deliveries coming forward
letter drops and things like that and I
think the key to that from previous
applications has always been the
communication of the of the site manager
and their team with the residents and
it's just finding the most appropriate
form for that communication to take in
terms of the indicative scheme
is indicative so that might not be what
comes forward we do have delivery of
policy compliant parking scheme
on site so if we were looking at
um
another town or Village it might be that
actually if it isn't if it doesn't have
the level of services within um
easy walking distance that we might be
looking at this and thinking actually we
want to see delivery of that parking to
that level and we want to see it done in
a way
um that minimizes impact on frontages
and car dominated development so I think
in that instance we'd be looking at a
design-based solution but I think at the
same time still Market are set out in
our settlement hierarchy is at the very
Pinnacle and that that is reflective of
the fact that there are so many services
and Facilities within walking distance
and I think
um as a parking authority if members
wanted to take a view at Reserve matters
that actually
what might drive behavioral change in
terms of changing people's primary mode
of Transport
if you don't deliver a level of parking
that would allow sort of two or more
cars per dwelling
then
do you drive that anyway by reducing the
level of parking in terms of the the
parking provider on site at present
highways have been consulted as to
whether that would be an intensification
um they're happy that at the moment the
level of traffic impact would be the
same excluding the hdb so we'd remove
the hgvs as a result and that's a
benefit for that area
in terms of smaller Vehicles the impact
would be largely the same truckies don't
only deal with hgbs they also do
servicing for the cars and smaller
Vehicles as well and
I think 50 to 60 full-time employees so
there's always been that traffic smaller
vehicle traffic to and from the site and
highways are content that the road
Network could
um maintaining that but as
the local planning Authority we might
want to consider whether or not we want
to see that modal shift and what things
we might consider from a planning
perspective would encourage that and we
could have control of that Reserve at
this stage
thank you
um
I I do have some questions but I'll let
councilor Mathison go next and then I'll
ask
um yeah I mean
firstly just a comment on what you said
about in that answer about the um
you know driving
um reduced vehicle movements by you know
by making less less parking provision
there is another thing
um and that is actually actually
um car free housing as it's called which
would require controlled parking Zone in
the vicinity so that there wasn't on
street parking that could be used
instead that we we did with a long time
ago I managed to keep into the Stow
Market air action plan there was a
sense8 actually well I know it relates
can you just hold it and mention it in
the debate because yeah questions now
okay so that's that's the the the
question particularly want to ask was
that in in such exchanges as you've had
so far with with Place Services I mean
the this submission is is just about
bats essentially is that is that really
that's just related to the demolition
um so I wondered if they'd recognize the
the opportunity of um biodiversity
Corridor
um to get to the cemetery I see that the
you've got that
um permissive path
um and I just wondered whether they'd
recognize that opportunity if they
haven't actually nudged them
um on the on the reserve matters level
so we do have
um suggested conditions from Matthew
King that talk about making sure we've
got our bat license
um in place for um Demolition and we'd
also be looking to secure a construction
management plan that looks to put
um ecology
um concerns at the heart of that as well
so that would be two documents
um we do also have conditions um to
secure Wildlife sensitive lighting
schemes within the site so that's
something that could come forward and
they've also noted uh the need for a
biodiversity enhancement scheme within
the site and they'd like to see that
concurrent with Reserve matters so we'd
have Clarity on that we do have
buildings that potentially might come
forward at Heights so we might look to
uh secure uh nesting for birds that
require that vertical drop for takeoff
um but yes we also have comments from
them as well about
um a biodiversity net gain statement as
well so we need to secure that by
condition and have
it on their submission
we need to do at this stage that's all
um thank you if if I'd just like to to
ask my questions
um
uh I notice in the conditions there's
something about EV
um
EV charging points as one of the
conditions to be agreed
um are we asking this developer to
provide EV charging for every dwelling
it's my first question
the crossing points on the roads can we
just confirm are they just going to be
drop curbs or is there actually going to
be any other Street Furniture
um and is The Pedestrian access to link
up with the permissive path is that
included as part of the access
Arrangements which are part of this
outline application those are my first
three I might have some more options
um
and let's let's tackle them
so in terms of uh securing the
permissive path we would want to see
that brought forward
um I don't see any reason why we
couldn't secure that high condition and
get that brought forward
um
you know a very sort of targeted
Landscaping scheme at that point would
seem to be
um would seem to make sense in terms of
um The Crossing points my understanding
is that drop curb flush with the
roadside and then the um the bubbly
bubbly pavement
um which I need to learn the proper name
for and then there was one other sorry
are we going to insist on this one point
it's normally one per dwelling I think
we would need to consider how that would
work within a flattered scheme
um whether there is a desire to provide
those
um across all parking spaces or whether
that is we provide
um the amount of parking for the flats
and then there's an area of VB charging
points available for them
um I know that in the past
um
sort of a County Council have been
resistant to the idea of provision of
electric vehicle charging points
um
for visitor parking
um but I think the tide is turning on
that as well and I think that could be
something we could look to explore
within Reserve matters to see where we
can deliver that because that would seem
to be a way to deliver that for the
flatted element and as part of the EV
charging points highways would normally
want to see
um
secure cycle storage and if we were
delivering that within the flatted
element of the building do we then
consider whether or not there needs to
be an EV charging point for electric
bicycles and their users as well which
would be useful to secure within applied
elements does that all come under the
that condition about provision for
electric vehicle charging points that
can be included in that I'll be looking
for that to come forward um now my my
other two questions are the construction
management plan does that also include
the demolition management plan and are
there is there anything
restricting the amount of material
that's removed from the site are we
expecting them to reuse material to mean
that it doesn't have to get transported
off the site and then a load of more
material to come back on and the other
question I've got is about the market oh
about the uh the Town Council have
pointed out in item 8 on The Late papers
that the percentage of affordables isn't
policy compliant so just wanted to
comment on that and do we have any
um restriction on the market housing mix
no that's all right
so in terms of uh I've separated out the
scheme of delegate demolition from the
scheme of construction
um because I think probably we'd want to
secure demolition of the buildings on
site prior to
instruction
and I think it would be it would be
useful to secure that
um separately that's not to say they
couldn't come forward currently if
that's if that's how but I feel separate
the amount in condition would work in
terms of
um material leaving the site I think
that depends on the remediation strategy
so we have that to be agreed I know that
some of the buildings look a bit fibrous
cementy and sometimes that is vibrous
cement and that's all it is sometimes
it's asbestos so where we have material
that has to leave the site I think we
can secure that and and we'd secure that
you know part of the scheme of
demolition would be what are you doing
with anything that does need to leave
the site and how is that being treated
and handled
in terms of bringing on
um new material there is allowance for
bringing on a certain amount of material
but anything over that needs approval
from the environment agency but normally
I don't think that would be that I don't
think that would be the case here but if
it was the case we could certainly look
to see
um a reserve matters level if we have if
we need to have them you know make sure
that they have the environment agency
approval we could condition side of that
with regards to the affordable housing
the Strategic housing officer notes as
well that I think we are 0.9 off having
35 and I think partly this comes down to
how mid suffolk's affordable housing
delivery policy was worded in the 2008
core strategy and its focused review and
effectively how affordable housing was
to be delivered
um within those documents was we wanted
um up to a maximum of 35 but if uh you
know if we were looking at the
calculation and it worked out that you
also need to deliver 0.4 of a house
round that off and and we would get to
the to the we would round down to the
nearest whole dwelling effectively
um the way that the emergent policy is
worded is that we seek
um 35 and if you are
um providing point nine of a dwelling
then that point nine needs to be
provided but as commuted some so we
would get the on-site delivery of 22 and
we'd get the
at how we get the commuted Zone
um at present it is effectively a race
between if we were to go forward how
quickly can the section 106 be drafted
and what adoptive plan is it coming
forward under because that might just
necessitate a small change in the
affordable housing Clauses of the
section 106 to secure that additional
commuted sum which we could then take
for delivery of affordable housing
within the district
um and the
um Market housing mix outline stage so
that would be to
come in and be agreed as part of the
reserve matters we have up to 65
dwellings on site that sets our ceiling
um that could change
um downwards but it couldn't change
upwards without a fresh application we
have no indicator how many that bedrooms
say we can't expect we have five that
they're all one and two bedrooms we have
an indicative
present
um we don't have a policy that would
require a specific mix
um to come forward and be agreed but we
would have control over that when we
come to details of Reserve matters
can we ask for the result
whatever that you know um whatever the
wording is to be similar to not much
different from the indicative mix
I think we could do we might want to
allow flexibility because I know dealing
with another site in I they do have a
mixed policy in their neighborhood plan
but actually that's now
five years old and they're looking at
actually reviewing their housing need
numbers
and based on their review of housing
need numbers they might want to change
their indicative mixed policy
um we could say broadly in
yeah we could agree a scheme
scheme of tenure and mix to be agreed
it's part of the reserve matters
uh does anyone else have any questions
of the officer
uh
[Music]
for the um applicant thank you
good afternoon thank you chair good
afternoon members my name is Jamie
Martin Edwards I'm a senior planner at
James baby planning I'm joined today by
James Bailey along with John biggin who
is the site owner and executive chairman
of Truck East limited between us we
should be able to answer any questions
that you may have on this outline
application at Violet Hill Road Stone
Market
the site is centrally located within the
settlement boundary of Stone Market town
and is well related to existing
residential development schools shops
Stow health and a large Recreational
Park
the site is used by Truck East which is
a well-established business for the
servicing repair and mot testing of hdv
vehicles and they've been on site since
the early 1970s
truck Easter currently in the final
stages of relocating to a purpose-built
site at Lawn Park Business Center just
off the A14 which was approved in the
summer of 2021. this relocation will
provide a much better opportunity for
the business to continue to grow and
expand importantly it has meant that
there is no net loss of employment land
as a result of this residential
application
the current site at Violet Hill Road is
unrestricted and can lawfully have
unlimited amount of hdvs that can enter
and exit the site
Violet Hill Road supports a health
facility primary school and other
residential uses and the removal of the
HG vehicle movements along this road can
only be seen as a benefit for the
existing and future residents of
stowmarket
in addition the site has three existing
separate accesses The Proposal will
reduce this down to a single point of
access ensuring the most effective use
of Brownfield land is achieved
the site's incredibly sustainable
location has even prompted SCC highways
to suggest that a reduction of 16 in
parking capacity on the site would be
acceptable as future occupants would be
less reliant on the private motor
vehicle to access services and
Facilities however to confirm the
indicative plan shown before you today
is fully policy compliance scheme for
parking
the application is for outline
permission including access and then
will deliver up to 65 dwellings
including up to 22 affordable units the
indicative layout shows that the
proposal can achieve through a diverse
mix of dwelling types including detached
semi-detached terrorists ground floor
accommodation and apartments
proposal is accompanied with a
parameters plan that will provide
members with certainty the areas of
development and the maximum story
Heights that can come forward at Reserve
matters stage
the site is within 250 meters of the
entrance of a recreational ground that
includes a host of facilities for public
enjoyment
proposing includes tactile pavement
improvements to a Crossing on Recreation
road to make this very short Journey
even more accessible
the scheme before you this morning has
been developed through extensive
discussions with your officers Suffolk
County Council highways local lead flood
Authority and there are no objections
from any statutory consulties I
therefore respectfully request members
endorse their officer's recommendation
today and approve this application
thanks for your time and we can answer
any questions that you may have thank
you chair thank you so do we have any
questions of the agent or the applicant
councilor penny
yeah I want to ask at this stage um
should should you get out outline
playing permission will you be giving
any consideration to an Energy
Efficiency measures such as cellular
panels and
air source heat pumps Etc when when the
full application comes through
thank you very much for the question um
yeah we are more than happy to have a
condition on the application which means
that we would have to provide an energy
sustainability report as part of any
reserve matters application and happy
for that to be concurrent with that
Reserve matters application I think to
be clear John biggin who's with me today
who currently owns the site has no
intention of developing the site itself
what we've done here is we've relocated
the business we're now looking to put
the residential use back onto the site
and then a new developer will come in
we're not looking to develop the site
that's why we've tried to ensure that
there's a degree of flexibility in terms
of the outline application the
parameters plan though has given you
some certainty about what that Reserve
matters is going to look like in terms
of heights and where locations of houses
will be so in terms of sustainability
credentials I think it's very important
that Reserve matters application is
backed fully with evidence that shows
exactly what's going to be provided and
that's an uplift in building control
rigs we expect to see in the condition
thank you thank you any further
questions
no so I will now
um oh sorry to somebody oh should I
cancel
um just quickly and sort of notice that
you said that there's been no overall
loss of employment which is great
because it's moving elsewhere but just
in terms of the sort of history of the
use of the site um obviously not for
today but for the future is there any
has any consideration been given to
creating employment opportunities on the
site through for example a little bit of
mixed use
um you know live work workshop space
which can be very successful in sort of
inner city residential areas
that's great thank you very much for
that question
um the site currently is marketing you
can find it now on the internet for us
up for sale there has been and I'm sure
John may be able to say in a bit more
detail there has been some commercial
interest in the site agreeing an outline
application today does not mean that it
will come forward as residential in the
future someone could buy it for
commercial site and indeed of course an
hgv operator could come on the site and
have an uncontrolled planning use on
there lawfully in its current use of the
site so uh commercial definitely is is
not discounted completely it really
depends on what the market determines
and of course hdv movements is quite
difficult in that area so it would be
unlikely that would come forward but but
it could continue
sale uh work sort of you know craft kind
of you know Workshop spaces which
there's often quite a bit of unmet
demand for rather than something that
was going to need lots of HD reads but
no I appreciate that and and if if
someone come forward during the
marketing campaign because it is up for
commercial and residential uses at the
moment and that's what they wanted to to
pursue that would come under a separate
application thank you thank you can I
just move on from that I mean should
they they get outline permission for
this type of residential use
is there anything that precludes them
putting whatever they're called live
work units on or would that require a
different application
I think that might require a slightly
different application but as Jamie says
you know
approval of this application
we'd have the reserve matters coming
forward but that doesn't mean to say
that that's what the the next owner of
the site wants to deliver if they wanted
to continue
to operate as Truckee star now then that
would be entirely lawful
um if they wanted to bring forward
Reserve matters for a residential scheme
um
in the scope of the outline permission
that we might want to consider approval
of today if they wanted to come back
with something completely different
um we would invite a new application and
consider it on its merits as well
forward
right so without any further questions
we now need to get in touch with
councilor Terence Carter who's going to
be on our teams link
um
so um are we able to oh there we are we
can see Terence
um I hope you can hear us and you can
see us so over to you
thank you I can hear you and I hope you
can hear me
um brilliant uh given that truck East uh
the truckee's site is currently already
located in a larger residential area in
fact building on a Brownfield site is
greatly preferred over a green and or
arable land I do want to say I do rather
prefer residential usage of this
development rather a possible industrial
or another hdv one
I welcome the increase of drop curbs
however as a Less Mobile pedestrian I
can state that fees already on the road
or Violet Hill are already quite
literally hit or miss
um
naturally I would like to strengthen the
green credentials of this and any
feature developments of those being in
sedation heat pumps solar and DV
charging and the like
however I would be amiss not to note
certain concerns
as I've noted with other applications in
the past
County and offices have a history of
promising vets seal section 106 Etc and
by like and the frying of Malia
existence day Market problems will
suddenly go away
we have had substantial developments
across the market in recent years
I'd imagine with a sizable seal
contribution
yet we're yet still provided Hill
doctors surgery has been unable to
increase its capacity
in recent months I've had residents
coming to me who have been turned away
from registering until to look at need a
market itself running at full capacity
stay Market schools are already fully or
over subscribed and again stay Market
does not currently have a dental surgery
which is currently offering places for
adult NHS patients
regarding this particular development
Violet Hill Road itself is already a
source of frustration for residents of
motorists alike
narrow Pathways and Pavements parking
can cause obstructions for both the
drivers and for make it impossible for
pedestrians with prams with walking aids
such a wheelchairs or maybe scooters
the impact on building on of the
development and the third for the impact
when residents move into a properties
and increase traffic flow can be seen as
slightly mitigated by withdrawal of
https and other vehicles entering the
site
yet there Remains the possible
obstruction to parking for businesses
neighboring Truck East should a
visibility need adjusting and could lead
to increased pavement parking
and I'd note that through these local
business was referred to as a sandwich
shop it is in fact a local restaurant
and a well-used service station which is
currently used by both the police by
drivers and that parking it currently is
used you'll find people parking there at
all hours when the when the when it's
open
so it does concern me wherever parking
will go to if that should be removed
I'd encourage as well liaising with
Trudy herself regards for development at
the Sea of mitigating this
uh the developer must be aware as well
regarding however frequent water buildup
pours from a Truckee site onto the roads
and over a Pavement
specifically in front of a Truck East
current entranceway and again Lower
towards the doctor's surgery
the water can reach up to my ankles and
that's when I'm driving on my mobility
scooter
and if I'm honest I've had to be rescued
more than once having flooded the motor
going by that stretcher Road
so a provision of Suds must be of a
standard that can handle that level of
runoff
with development is currently could you
just wait a minute um
sorry about that Terence uh we just had
to listen to the fire alarm issue uh if
you just go back because we missed the
last bit of what you just said so just
want to go back a sentence or two thank
you
okay I'll try and find my place and I'm
sorry for mumbling as well trying to
read this through
um
I was just covering regarding the water
runoff from a site and how it's flooded
my Mobility Scooter engine where I made
a number of times and having to be
rescued due to water runoff so we would
definitely need the subprovision to be
capable to actually
handle that amount of water from the
area
um
you've already covered regarding the
Paloma threshold affordable home so I
don't need to estate that
but I would say about it doesn't
currently offer any Bungalows which was
brought up when the disability form was
consulted these are in great demand and
so would be underrepresented across
mid-suffolk especially in terms of
affordable and social housing
um and you've covered as well of the
social affordable homes being condensed
in one part of the site and with well
I'd worker made more inclusive and
integrated layouts and not one that
seems isolating or singled out
in order to fully support this
development
um
layout more conclusive or allowing for
green spaces and planting and keeping
with what is already on display around a
White House and the area alike
accessible and planted property like
accessible and adaptive properties with
an appropriate door width on the ground
floor Apartments
and the specific specifications can be
found on the report for mid-suffet
distributed forum and if possible again
to offer a bungalow Foundation
regarding layout a resident has noted to
be how the blocks could be repositioned
slightly towards the northeast corner of
a site allowing opening up for the uh
for a parking area
and also staggering the tool buildings
within streetscape to really reduce the
number of residents who would be
overlooked and the residents of Wade
house and vice versa
this would also retain any views that
any other blocks
um retain any reviews are blocks would
benefit from
I would also note that had it not been
for my intervention
uh The Stone Market Town Council would
not have added near opportunity to
comment on this sort of application
haven't been missed which is why it's in
relate papers
um
for Less to say about this episode
better but I do fully endorse and I'm
welcoming to look and refer to be
comments made by a Town Council fully as
well as be disability forum
live
noted these again here but you have
eased them in front of you so
I think
I think it's best to either end my
present presentation here
thank you
councilor Mathison yeah um
in terms of I mean I think I think
again bungalows in the middle of Stone
Market it's going to be fairly fairly
difficult to persuade uh any developer
to do but
[Music]
um
do do we know do you know are you aware
of any cases where
um good quality
um
vision for
accessible homes on the ground floor of
blocks of flats and that kind of thing
is is that going to be something that's
workable and and we'll need to come back
to nasty officers afterwards if um
if if something we can write in or not
it would be workable if the door wits
were a provision and making sure that
these surfaces were level and accessible
so no loss use the shingles and making
sure the pathways are
um well yeah basically accessible but
you know about not having Bungalows and
stone markets well in the most recent
application that's gone through for the
uh old police station in stone market
across the road from this development
has had actually additional Bungalows
into it
so we are looking to increase in
Bungalows and stone markets right around
reducing the number
any further questions from councilor
Carter
thank you and I presume we've had
nothing from Council Napier
okay so
um I will now open the item Up For
Debate
um who would like to um
um yeah so
given the the this is paragraph 2.3 page
112 where we've got a proposed
housing mix
um which I think he was saying was it
was only indicative
um but assuming that was what might come
forward
um are we able to to put some m42
um
constraints onto onto that at this stage
or is that going to be all after the
reserve matters
Bungalows on site and where the ground
floor
Flats would be appropriate on this site
instead and I think that would be I
think it would be interesting strategic
and yeah I agree provided they can be
made
um part M compliant
um then I think that would be what we're
looking to try and Achieve and I would
note that our strategic housing
colleagues quite often look for all of
um anything that's single story
um whether that's flats or Bungalows
that comes forward they want that to be
provided as
um convertible
and convertible so that if we have
someone on the
um
wait list who needs something converted
then we can step in convert and then we
have a property available for them but
at the same time if we just have someone
who has
mobility issues that don't quite require
that we we can leave it as is
the council the Carters did
um you know he said you know when you
you think about it you've got a block of
flats and it's got an in front entrance
and a back entrance and of course if
you're going to do that then you need to
start at the beginning and The Wider
entrance
which would be compliant so that you can
get into the ground floor flat
um so I you know I think that's that's
useful stuff to pick up for the future
thank you um can I can I also make the
can Carry On from something that
councilor Carter said and is mentioned
in the Town Council comments about the
sandwich bar and some sort of liaison
with them and with proper communication
with the Town Council so we have had
this sort of community liaison type um
condition can we put that here that the
um whichever developer it is that takes
on the site must have some sort of
liaison with other local businesses and
the
um the other you know the police station
the health center the primary school
Town Council all the sort of neighboring
and people have got an interest in it
basically and have some sort of
community liaison so that whatever they
put on this site will work for them as
well yeah I think so I think the
construction method statement is a is a
primary way to have that to set up those
um
communication Pathways
during construction and during
development when things are probably
going to be most disrupted
I think that makes perfect sense
so um anyone like to open the item for
debate
a counselor headingham
thank you
I I really think this is a good um good
development here and I'm happy to
propose that you know frankly along with
all the things that we've discussed just
lately that um that um then I'm happy to
go along with the officer's
recommendation for approval I like the
idea that we can put something in about
the ground floor Flats um being
accessible and um
I like the amount of car park spaces
that's great you know I just you know I
hate seeing new development and you know
so many cars is parked off on the
pavement and all the rest of it there
just hasn't been enough um parkings one
that's a really good point and I think
we need to tie down the green
credentials and all the rest of it but
apart from that I think it's all good
is that a formal proposal so I need to
find a seconder for that proposal
Council of War boys uh did you want to
say anything at the same time
I'm happy to uh to Second it it's a
appropriate use of a Brownfield site
uh I think we've covered all the points
with the the Town Council brought
forward in particular days and the local
businesses
um so I'm happy to Second it
account counselor Lawrence did you put
your hand to hold a council had it hard
Harding them I thought I thought I saw
another hand pump up there
um anybody else want to say anything
um well well I'll just comment because
because of course Truck East has moved
to my ward
so I'm fully aware of where all the hgv
movements have gone to and yes it was I
I'll appreciate that that the old A14
um
fast holy New Street is a much bigger
road than violet Hill Road
um and uh but that has does have a
knock-on effect for hgvs traveling
through wallpaper and elmswell but yes
that's probably slightly better
than getting them off Violet Hill Road
so um and it is an employment site it's
a big employment site it's got lots of
lighting
um but yeah moving it out that was not a
best location for a truck um servicing
uh place
um if only we had two-way access off the
A14 at lawn Farm it would be even better
but we have it so I do think that this
is a
a good use of an old Brownfield site as
long as we can make sure that we've got
all those green credentials and we've
got some tree planting and some
biodiversity Improvement and I would
like to see the um the back end the
footpath entrance being secured by
condition as well as the access and some
sort of liaison group set up with the
local businesses and Town Council
um so I think this is on the whole a
good development
um and uh and I I hope we can make sure
we've got all the right conditions here
at outline stage so that when it does
come forward at Reserve matters we get
something that we we can be proud of so
as anybody else got anything to say
counselor yeah I I mean the the the the
one note that I I made reading the
papers and so on is
um you know it's a ask officers you know
are you confident
um that putting 65 on this site is going
to leave enough space to resolve these
the issues about parking layout which is
I think sort of commented and criticized
and and The Pedestrian connectivity and
the Landscaping
um and the and the public open space
with you know play equipment
um you know it it's very difficult to
judge that
um you know with the rural ones here we
can solve well let's look at the let's
look at the density and so on so you
um
this is more difficult to kind of get
your head around sometimes
um because a lot of it's all the the 65
a lot of it's packed into the into the
blocks of flats isn't it
um
so you know you're you're confident that
65 is okay
um
comfortable
design if if we come back with the
reserve matters that doesn't meet our
expectations we'll give you a
recommendation of refusal
yeah but which will be difficult if
we've said 65 and we can't fit them in
we've said up to 65 so they can always
go down yeah it never happens they can't
go up without fresh planning application
we
have control of that and and if members
reminded to approve the outline then if
we did get something that sort uplift
we'd either need to have clear and
convincing justification or we might
want to say well actually we've got a
scheme for a latter number on the site
that we think is is preferable and that
might be something to address then but
um you know when we have
um detail of
appearance layout scale Landscaping
there'll be you know an opportunity for
members to join the rule over it as well
not just officers is there anything we
want to write in now about the you know
what I was saying in the questions that
to achieve the best biodiversity
connectivity through to the cemetery
because cemetery is notoriously a really
good biodiversity and it's
it's almost there
School field in between only
um is there anything we need
I think that could be covered within the
um enhancement scheme the biodiversity
enhancement scheme
um I think we'd have some benefit coming
forward as part of the landscaping for
Reserve matters
um
but in terms of
delivering a complete Corridor we're
probably slightly at the mercy of the
school and whether or not they want to
want to see that but I take the point
and I think
um you know that that permissive path is
already quite well to read anything we
can do
um
the biodiversity of that area probably
would be a positive as well
good
so does anybody else want to say
anything or can we ask the area planning
manager to to read out the proposal and
any additional
um conditions or guidance notes that are
going to be included thank you
yep so we're looking at approving as
recommendation on pages 118 to 119 and
then additional conditions we're looking
at agreeing the housing mix including
accessibility of ground floor Flats the
footpath linked to be secured although I
know that there is also a condition
about a delivery of our state roads and
foot pass but I think between them they
should knit together and then the
community liaison group to be included
in the construction method statement
condition I hope that was everything
is there anything that we don't think is
covered uh councilor Elkin
something about
with that coming I think that might is
that already covered in your in your
schema which force bullet point down
which says scheme of demolition is not
included in that between that and
further investigation remediation
uh vocational
we would cover that off between those
two conditions
are we are we happy with that so I asked
the governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress in your app
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for that's carried thank you
um so we now move on to item eight on
our agenda which is site inspection do
do we have any site inspection requests
that need to be reported to committee
let me see yeah thank you uh we now have
the item number nine which is to confirm
the confidential minute of the planning
committee meeting held on the 21st of
June now if there's anyone who wishes to
discuss the contents of the confidential
minute we have to go into closed session
so if you um uh are just happy to accept
it that I think we can not have to have
the vote to exclude the public so does
any of do any of you have want to
discuss anything that is in the
confidential minutes
um in which case I think we can just
have a proposal to accept them is that
right yeah so we just need a proposal
and a second uh councilor having um and
seconded by councilor Mathison that we
accept those uh confidential minutes
um and we can do this on a show of hands
uh apparently so all those in favor of
accepting the confidential minute
thank you yes that's unanimous thank you
uh thank you so um I now uh formally
close the meeting at 13 40.
um